I don't even think they're nuclear bombs
work.
It's all posturing probably,
right?
Yeah.
Do Do,
do Abby Martin were like,
wow,
you have a doom shirt on.
Powerful street cred with the kids.
They're going back to the Wolfenstein
doom days.
Old School id software.
Hell,
he had that game.
That game was awesome.
I missed him or due to the new ones are
pretty bad movie.
I never saw it.
I did.
It was terrible.
Was it the first person shooters so bad?
No,
no,
no.
There was a.
There was a first person shooter movie
like something Harry or something like
that.
Hardcore hardcore.
Henry.
Henry and Henry.
Was it good?
That was nuts.
It really just felt like you're watching
a video game the whole time.
It was absolutely insane.
What was it?
Good.
I don't know if it was just very
entertaining.
Well,
there is.
Yeah,
that's right.
The Rock.
When he had hair.
Wow.
That's right.
Old School guy.
That was a terrible movie was so dumb.
Why does it look like that?
I remember doing being super red and
orange and this is blue.
Come on.
Who the hell's going on?
Why is he listed first?
Because nobody knew who the raclette
Karl Urban.
Exactly.
That's how old that movie was.
What else is Karl?
Urban Bennon Dude,
I just had a twitter argument with
Chelsea Clinton.
It's like these people don't understand,
never respond to someone who's like way
less than a year,
you know,
she like,
she,
like,
I called her,
I basically,
I called her parents were criminals and
she was like,
yeah,
you know,
I should have listened more during,
during the 2003 Iraq war today,
antiwar activist.
But she initially called people who were
protesting the Afghanistan war and like
the AUMF anti American.
So she was like,
yeah,
because there was a story that came out
that said Chelsea Clinton actually with
like American flags and all these things
like went and disrupted an antiwar
protest after nine slash 11.
Yeah,
like a group of Patriots and in probably
22 or something.
I mean maybe,
maybe younger.
So then people were calling her out and
being like,
you know,
like mother,
like daughter,
because there's stories of Hillary
Clinton,
like really working hard to quell the
protest,
the Vietnam war protests on,
on campus and stuff.
As the president of the Republican Young
Republicans Club.
She was the president really just pre or
post Kent state this.
Ooh,
good question.
Really good question.
I don't know it was when the whole that
it'd be hard to defend it after that.
Right after people are shot.
But yeah.
So Chelsea actually responded to me.
I was floored because I was like,
your dad killed 500,000
babies in Iraq with the sanctions and
your mom voted for the Iraq war.
I was like,
why don't you protest them?
And she was like,
you know,
it was like what she just said.
She was like,
you know,
I wasn't really.
She was,
I don't think that people protesting the
Afghanistan war,
anti American.
She was like,
you know,
140 characters limiting.
I was like,
do you see that?
I just called your parents were
criminals
and you're actually responding whatever,
whatever WTF.
Just put the blinders on.
Oh my God.
And then she was like,
I was talking about the Americans who
denounce,
like you know that America is an
imperialist warmonger.
I was like,
it is the countries in an imperialist
war mongering country that's killed
millions of people use cert,
the democratic processes of dozens of
countries and the world actually thinks
that America is the number one threat to
global peace.
So I actually agree with the Americans.
You denounce Chelsea.
It was nuts.
So that was a highlight of the day.
Yeah,
that's not a good look for her.
No,
she should probably stay off twitter for
a few years.
It's like,
dude,
just just step back.
I mean,
you sound awful.
I know that you're trying to get in the
public spotlight in and get that
momentum behind you.
I mean,
people are already talking about her
running in 20 slash 20 Michelle Obama,
Chelsea Clinton together.
The two of them together that Jay.
Can you imagine?
Whoa.
That would be hilarious.
What's the problem is as soon as you
engage with someone that's calling
anyone who is absolutely responsible for
death,
a war criminal,
as soon as you engage,
it's like,
well,
then you have to define what do you
think is a war criminal?
Like what's okay for you?
Is it okay if 10,000
babies?
Now he said,
I mean like you could kind of call any
president ever a war criminal except for
maybe Jimmy Carter.
Jimmy Carter gets slippery because he
was really a peaceful man and a really
weird situation and I think a lot of
people capitalized on that weakness,
including Ronald Reagan,
which is the reason why the hostages in
Iran weren't even released until after
Reagan took office and nuts.
That's a crazy story.
It's a crazy story because they
literally kept those people prisoner and
negotiated with their release based on
Ronald Reagan winning the election to
make them look better.
Those people were prisoner longer
because of Reagan,
like they could have just gotten them
out in a total,
nonpartisan way.
They could've said,
hey,
these are Americans.
Let's get them home like fuck out of
there.
They wanted to move those chips around
the board.
Let's move this,
let's move these pieces.
It was,
it was almost as good a that Chelsea
Clinton recognition as when John Mccain
tweeted a segment that I did about him
on breaking the set,
which was like the most scathing
segment,
calling him as senile crazy war criminal
like sadistic fuck.
And he like tweeted it out and he was
like,
thanks Vlad.
Vladimir Vladimir Putin.
If lad continues his attacks against me
and tweeted out to like is,
that's really what he said.
Yeah.
Now you don't.
You didn't have anybody telling you what
to do.
No,
but God can.
You heard about all the DNI report,
that intelligence report that basically
claimed that I,
along with another show cost Hillary
Clinton the election.
I mean this intelligence report came out
after months and months.
Everyone's waiting with baited breath
thinking,
okay,
we're finally going to get evidence that
Russia hacked the election,
right?
This claim that Russia hacked the
election and then they come out with
this report.
Half of it was just bashing our tea and
it named my shows
specifically,
and it said the show covered fracking,
occupy Wall Street,
um,
government greed,
Hillary Clinton's war crimes.
It's like,
and they basically just insinuated that
these things are what cost Hillary
Clinton the election,
a show that had gone off the air two
years before.
It's nuts,
but people are terrified of ridiculous
shit.
The intelligence community,
how do they do that?
Then how could they do that if you're
showing off the year,
two years before the previous criticism?
Yeah.
They said that that was when like Russia
had begun to foment like all this
descent and um,
and trying to discredit American
democracy.
Like that's when Russia really like
began the propaganda campaign was when
my show,
I was like the vector.
I was like this,
this person that was put in there and
started to unravel democracy.
It's crazy.
It's an enormous amount of power,
but you didn't know yet.
But what's even crazier about it is it's
like,
yeah,
of course our t is pro Russian.
It's fucking called Russia today.
Of course they're going to cover Putin
in a positive light.
The crazy thing is that the intelligence
report essentially said that covering
real issues like covering greed and
fracking are our Russian propaganda
talking points and that was really bad
because you're.
You're calling reality propaganda like
people are living in poverty in this
country,
half the countries and poor living
paycheck to paycheck,
so you can't call like covering that
reality propaganda.
Russian propaganda.
That's fucking reality is slippery.
They're working for something like Rt.
If they are going to view poutine in a
positive light but they are going to
criticize clinton like it is.
He does get a lIttle slip.
Are you happy you're not there anymore?
I am happy that I'm doing the reporting
that I'm doing or just like more just on
the ground investigation.
Like since I last saw you,
I've been to palestine.
Like now I finally like really have a
sense of these issues that I was
covering from the studio and and feel
like I know them more,
you know,
after going and talking to the people in
the communities and stuff like that.
So the,
the journalism is definitely much
better.
I don't have any boss,
I'm just doing my own things.
And you totally didn't know.
Well,
I'm working for telos sore.
So it's like a latin american state
funded media.
Now,
just to close to soros,
he's the one that makes the weed
stronger.
Did you read that?
Controls everything.
I chose the same as he's making the weed
stronger.
Can I ask you a question?
What one does a billionaire become a
globalist?
Because why is not?
Why is rex tillerson not a globalist,
the exxon mobil ceo?
Like one question that this whole thing
about like soros is this globalist and
all these people are against the
globalist yet trump,
it's totally fine to have rex tillerson
and all these goldman sachs bankers and
the government and why are they not
globalists capital move across the left
wing.
Democrats with money are globalists.
What does that mean?
Trump's in power.
So that's how it works.
So if trump wasn't in power,
then it would be rupert murdoch.
So it'd be the one.
He'd be the evil bandit.
It's nuts.
I mean,
yes.
Soros is
a horrible person who's done a ton of
crazy shit,
but like so as rex tillerson,
so are all these people,
you know,
betsy devoss is his psychotic.
These people are christian
fundamentalists who have used trump as
like the trojan horse to get into power.
These people have been vying for power
for the last 30 years.
These christian evangelicals,
mike pence,
betsy devoss,
you know betsy devoss,
his brothers.
Eric prince,
right?
The blackwater guy.
Yeah.
That's her brother.
Who is a divorce.
Her married name?
Yeah.
What is her deal again?
So she,
her and her,
I think her husband's names dick,
but um,
she married into this like education
privatization scheme where it's like a
super right wing religious extremist
education privatization thing where
they're trying to like get vouchers for
creationism and all these things like
private schooling that teaches
creationism.
And so they funneled the betsy devoss
like family.
Um,
I forget what the organization's called,
but they've funneled millions and
millions of dollars into this sCam.
I'm meanwhile her brother,
Eric Prince.
You know what he's been doing.
I mean,
he's now working for like Qatar,
Saudi Arabia,
I think it's United Arab Emirates and I
think he literally,
when arab spring broke out,
he took his whole business over there
was like,
listen,
there's a way to prevent those war.
So tHey have like a private militant
group over there or rather a mercenary
group over there that's kind of running
their,
their army.
It's so crazy.
It's like this family is working
together to create these like obedient
christianized soldier children who are
growing up in schools thinking that,
you know,
the kingdom and the messiah gonna come.
I mean it's nuts.
And,
and,
and when she was in the confirmation
hearing,
of course she was the only one that
actually wasn't confirmed in mike pence
had to do the tiebreaker because
everyone was like,
she's the most unqualified person.
She cAn't spell.
She's like a total moron.
I'm,
why is she even like in the running
here?
And she lied multiple times in the
hearing.
She was like,
yeah,
no,
that was a clerical error when it said
that I was vice president or on the
board of this organization,
which is this right wing extremist hate
mongering organization that's funneled
millions of dollars to knock down all
the the gay marriage propositions and
all these states and stuff like that.
So she lied and said she wasn't on the
board,
but really when you look at the
paperwork,
she was on the board for like 10 years
or something.
I mean,
how could a clerical error happened?
Not that long.
So it's sick.
These people are sick.
Mike pence is a disgusting person who he
fought for conversion therapy for gay
people.
Those people are on.
What does this say?
Refused to agree with democrat,
that schools are no place for guns,
citing one school that needs one to
protect she grizzly grizzlies bears.
She really said this.
First of all,
grizzly bears are rarely predatory
towards people and especially not in
schools that don't go to school.
All.
I don't think that's ever happened.
Bedside and you know what you could do,
you could just shut the door and then
the kids cannot get in the school and
won't try.
Unbelievable.
The kids guns that didn't.
Someone say like the.
The solution is sandy hook is giving the
children.
The teachers don't think that it would
work either.
I mean it wouldn't be the worst idea to
have some military presence in a place
that where people you really feel that
they're threatened,
but the question is like,
why are they threatened?
LIke you have a fucking mentally ill
person who has access to guns.
The real issue is keeping track of
mentally ill people I would imagine,
and also down that mentally ill thing.
Like wasn't that a vettIng thing that I
think the nra actually shut down that
we.
That mentally ill people can actually
still purchase firearms.
Am I wrong about that?
That's a good question.
I think in terms of like what is the
medication they're on because finds
mental illness.
Yeah.
Well the federal government was trying
to deny licenses to people that have
marijuana,
medical marijuana prescriptions.
They were trying to deny them handgun
licenses.
Who were firearms license.
Hilarious.
It's crazy because you could be on
oxycontIn and all sorts of
disassociative drugs,
ssri which are almost entirely connected
to school shootings and mass shootings.
If you look at mass shootings,
the vast majority of them either were on
psych meds or have been on psych meds,
were off psych meds and of course then
the argument,
the real scientific argument is that
they had not necessarily the cause,
you know,
the causation and correlation are not
necessarily connected.
So no one knows exactly why those people
do that.
But if you've ever talked to someone who
was on zoloft or anything,
one of the problems is there's a
disassociation with reality and the that
nothing bothers you anymore.
Like I had a friend who was on it and
she was telling me,
she's like,
I could come home and my house could be
on fire and I'd be like,
oh,
my house is on fire.
She's like the dog burning.
She wanted to write a book called.
I lost a year of my life because she,
she literally like nothing mattered.
Everything was gray and black and white
and there was no color and it was just
weird.
She was like,
my whole life just happened in a year,
and then I got off of them and then I
was like,
oh,
okay.
Now I'm a person again.
Like,
what the fuck happened to me for a year?
That's horrible.
Here's the shit out of me.
How many people they just throw on those
goddamn things and I know that some
people are,
that they benefit from them.
I've had friends that have benefit from
them.
I know there's a positive,
but I,
I gotta think there's too many people
that are going right to them and not
exercising,
not changing their diet,
not trying to meditate,
not trying to seek some sort of a
positive avenue for their,
their life and their energy and see if
that has any effect on their depression.
It just scares the shit out of me.
Yeah.
No,
it's crazy.
I mean,
how crazy is this jeff?
Sessions like taking us back to regional
madness.
He wants to just say no again.
He wants to,
he wants to restart.
Just say,
no,
this guy's nuts.
He's oLd as fuck.
That's a part of the problem.
And along with that guy,
dick and he.
Any guys still named dick?
What's her name?
Just husband.
Oh yeah.
DIck device.
If you're sold that,
your fucking parents called you dick
silver.
Yeah.
the last dick that I know his dick
tracy,
which is like,
you know an old nicole.
Yeah.
You're so old that the name dick wasn't
referred to.
It wasn't a dick back then.
Right?
That's a fucking old.
You are so crazy that it's time to not
be in charge of drug policy.
There's no way you're thinking clear.
There's no way he said it.
He said no.
Good people smoke weed.
No good people smoke marijuana.
That's just not true,
jeff.
Yeah.
That's not true.
We're good people.
I'm a nice person.
Were very good and pay my taxes.
You fuck?
Yeah.
What else did I just read that just
they're racist origins of making weed
illegal obviously tweeted something like
that a couPle of days ago about the
racist origins.
It was a rolling stone piece and the
racist origins with the drug.
It was entireLy designed during the
nixon administration.
This,
the whole schedule one designation for
marijuana,
cocaine or cocaine,
cocaine has medical use,
believe it or not,
scheduled to,
but marijuana,
mushrooms,
all these different psychedelic drugs.
I believe.
So.
I'm pretty sure bizarre medical use of
cocaine.
Um,
I think heroin as well check that jamie
just in case.
But there is a medical use for cocaine.
There's a medical use for heroin,
opiates,
things along those lines.
So I think they have different
designations because of that because
they still refuse to admit there's a
medical use for marijuana despite all
the millions of people using it for
positive,
including kids wIth epilepsy.
I mean it's a believable in autism.
I have a good friend who has a kid that
had severe seizures and there was
nothing they could do about it until
they started giving him.
They would give him hash in like a piece
of melon,
you know,
like,
and all the sudden gone like all
seizures and he's more communicative.
He's more responsive.
He's got pretty severe cognitive issues.
Autism and uh,
and also the seizures.
It's like,
it's pretty severe.
And the only thing that helps them as
medical marijuana.
Yeah.
For me,
I just get high.
I just don't be clear folks.
I mean,
don't be confused.
I mean I,
I'm,
I'm pro all those things.
Yeah.
It was basically a knee operation was
okay back in the day if you were making
money.
So if there was businesses behind it,
cocaine's stunning.
It's used as a local anesthetic.
I never let the dentist dude fentanyl
that shit prints at scheduled to,
oh my god,
morphine scheduled to opm scheduled to
cody and scheduled to I believe a meth
schedule to.
Yeah.
And how um,
oh,
in that article it said that the south
past all of these anti cocaine laws
because after the race riots and then
they were like scared.
And then in san francisco they pass an
opium ordinance targeting chinese
people.
So it was like kind of racially bent
back in the day.
But of course we'd was never an Industry
behind it.
So they just,
you know,
didn't have the capitalized fuck man.
Jeff sessions is a little little elf.
Why is he,
it's so bizarre.
He's was just like this old man who's
totally out of touch and for some reason
he's just.
What are they going to do though?
Because California just legalized weed.
I mean,
how are they going to continue with dea
raids and stuff?
Yeah,
I think no,
but they are doing a bunch of sneaky
shit like Washington dc as a
disproportionate number of arrests on
people of color for marijuana.
They're getting arrested even though
Washington dc has legal recreational
marijuana,
there was still arresting black people.
It's fucked up.
It's really weird.
There was a whole article on it.
They can't really.
They're arresting them,
but they can't really do anything,
so they just arresting them there.
They just go through the system.
They get processed and I mean I don't
think they're getting jay.
They're obviously getting jailed
initially or at least brought in for to
be booked,
but it's just the idea that this is
still going on despite all the evidence.
It just shows you what a corrupt system.
Totally.
And americans just totally want legal,
recreational marijuana.
Well that's the only thing holding that
sessions got back.
Is it 57 percent of americans support,
legalized recreational marijuana,
which is just unprecedented this,
it's never been that high before.
And that's people willing to answer
polls.
I would venture that if you really got
down and dirty with a bunch of people
like you and I that aren't answering
polls,
I bet you're going way over 70 percent
because it just doesn't make any sense.
And when dc passed the law,
um,
it was overwhelming and that's where all
the legislators are.
Like obviously they want it to.
So what the hell is holding his back
here?
You guys are in dc,
you all smoke weed is a massive,
massive amount of money that still being
spent by really odd groups like prison
guard lobbies,
which is really crazy.
Then we use unions.
Yeah.
They want more people in jail so they
can make more money and get more hours.
It's so crazy.
It is like vampires shit because you
think about what you're doing.
You're literally trying to suck money
out of people's lives.
I mean,
they don't look at it that way.
They're looking at it like we're going
to keep jobs for these american prison
workers.
We're going to keep american jobs just
trying to get create jobs.
Joe.
Now we're creating jobs.
don't you see the.
The good thing behind this record,
it's spooky as a comedian.
I mean I know that like the outright is
kind of blended in with like this anti
pc culture that I think comedians relate
to,
but like do you just wake up and things
like,
holy shit,
Donald Trump.
Is the president ever?
Are you laying stone?
Isn't it?
Before my last special,
my last special aired in november,
which is right before the election,
and I was like,
do you know how fucking close we are?
And people were laughing,
guy,
he's not going to win.
I'm like,
no,
he's fucking right there.
It could happen.
And then boom,
he became president and I just like,
wow.
It's so surreal,
but it,
it highlights to me how preposterous
this system of having one person run
this whole thing is.
It doesn't an any.
I know there's a cabinet.
I know.
I understand the legislation legislative
process.
I understand there's a senate and the
congress,
I can't.
I get it,
but still he's got a lot of fucking
power.
He's did.
What was the thing that he shut down?
He shutting down the epa database.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
When they had to like start rogue
twitter accounts,
they're like,
we need to put out the climate data in
case trump deletes it.
It'S like,
how does,
how does he have this much?
exactly.
How does the executive branch have this
much power?
I think he's just doing shit and then
they have to stop it somehow or another
and no one wants to stop it.
Like he's.
He's just doing shit.
Whether or not he can or can't do shit.
I mean he's just doing it and then you
have to figure out a way to reverse it,
but it's already getting done like the
epa standards that some spooky shit
because that's the literally the ground
that we grow our food in.
The water that we drink,
the air that we breathe is one of the
most important things,
but it becomes this.
It becomes this ideological issue
between right and left were right,
wants work and jobs and industry and
left once water to be clean and like
it's fucking insane that that became one
of those issues that it's.
It's an ideological thing that if you're
on the right,
you're supposed to,
if not deny climate change.
You're supposed to ignore it at the very
least,
and if you're on the left,
you're supposed to be a tree hugger and
a hippie and you're supposed to be all
about clean water.
The fact that these people can make
these distinctions like that and then
figure out a way to make money despite
that you're poisoning the mother earth.
It's just.
It's insane.
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's like there's gotta be another way
to make money,
guys.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
There's got to be this coal mining
thing.
You're going to read
night coal mining.
Trump kept calling it clean coal like,
what are you talking about?
Are we living in the fifties,
eat it,
drink the water in flint,
and it was like,
oh,
water is clean.
We're all good.
FuckIng evacuate.
Immediately
pa as a different store,
the agency says it has no plans to shut
down the website,
much less bury the data it makes
accessible and never did.
Okay,
so they are fighting back.
No way.
So the epa is not.
So the data is not.
So were.
Who were those robots?
Can fake news?
Who were those rogue accounts that were
saying,
oh,
we're gonna
the,
uh,
the story where you came from like a
context,
or excuse me,
data taken out of context from the trump
administration.
They are gonna maybe take out 31 percent
of the epa budget,
but they're just going to get to the
pentagon.
You heard about that too,
right?
Twenty five percent in the cut in the
workforce.
So they're going to get rid of 25
percent of the epa far as the workforce
and in 31 percent of the money.
That's hilarious.
So that means the people that remain are
gonna leave.
because look,
if you cut out 31 percent and then 25
percent of the workforce,
that means you're cutting out more money
than you are cutting out people.
so I guarantee you that's going to,
that's goIng to equate to people
leaving.
Yeah.
And the whole like climate accords or
whatever that,
you know,
the us is not only the biggest polluter,
the pentagon pollutes more than any
other entity in the world.
But then yeah,
the pentagon itself,
just the military.
Oh yeah.
All the billions of plastic debris in
the ocean.
All the fucking bombs exploding.
God knows what we're doing around the
world.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean when the pentagon is the biggest
polluter and then you pull out of the
paris accords or whatever,
like trump was just like,
yeah,
like we're going to pull out of that
climate change agreement.
It's like,
well,
who's going to hold it together?
Then it already wasn't enough weight and
you know,
it's like these.
And then he just puts exxon mobil in
charge of the state department.
I mean,
it's so much crazier than halliburton.
It's so much crazier than condoleeza
rice has ties to exxon,
the actual ceo.
I just can't even wrap my mind around
it.
It is amazing.
I mean,
it's amazing that we didn't learn from
the dick cheney
exxon.
They're like,
run the country like a business.
It's like,
all right,
I'm just going to put actual ceos in
charge of all these departments and
that's going to be good.
Like,
is thAt fucking good?
Well,
it would be good if you streamline the
business and tried to make it more
practical and cut out waste and
bureaucracy and red tape and made it
better for everybody,
but as soon as you start saying things
like,
we're going to shut down all those
satellites that track global warming,
like,
whoa,
why?
Why you doing that?
Shouldn't we know what the fuck is
happening?
Shouldn't we know?
Shouldn't we have good estimates is when
the people in miami,
you're going to drown,
right?
Because they're going to drown.
They're going to droWn in a 40 or 50
years or so.
People in miami are fucked.
Those people are fucking put that head.
The head of the epa is a climate change
denier.
He was a guy like embroiled in a lawsuit
against the epa.
Yeah.
That's not good,
rIght?
No,
I would say that's not a good thing.
Now that guy have you look at every
department,
rick perry,
the guy who's,
you know,
we go from dancing with the stars and
now he's in charge of the department.
He wanted to abolish.
Did you on dancing with the stars?
Yeah.
And then he was like,
he wanted to abolish the energy
department and then of course he's
appoinTed to run the energy department
and didn't even know what the hell it
did the energy department,
like as is what houses are like nuclear
weapons.
So it's like,
okay,
did you know that?
Like how stupid are you?
How are you running for president?
How about ben carson to.
He make him like department of houSing
or some shit like surgeon general.
He's got damn doctor.
Yeah.
like instead of Like a.
Yeah,
instead of some surgeon,
he's like,
yeah,
didn't you mAke him in charge of like
neurosurgery?
He's like a fucking neurosurgeons.
Shouldn't you be in charge of educating
the board on are the,
you know,
the government on the science behind
neurosurgery and like let's,
let's stay on board with all this
research and science.
Utilize your expertise.
Maybe it's like a joke.
I mean,
the whole thing is like a reality show.
Looking back on it,
I do think,
you know,
I believed all the polls and I was,
I don't know why because there are,
you know,
it's coming from like this ivory tower
elite who's totally out of touch with
the rest of the country,
but I really did believe that trump had
no chance because I thought hillary
would steal the vote.
I mean if it came down to,
and I'm like,
they have,
they have measures in place.
They're really like,
locked this dowN.
I was like,
there's still a way,
and when he won I just couldn't believe
it.
But looking back on it,
it makes so much sense.
It's like,
how could he not have one?
Hillary was the most corrupt clay
candidate,
30 years of just a legacy of horrible
death and destruction or husband and
ruined the economy.
Horrible arrogance,
right?
Bill clinton ruin the economy.
Deregulation up the ass.
He was an officer yet.
And that's what happens right before it
craShes,
right?
The buildup of all the banking
regulations,
the telecom communications act,
prison at a street.
It was clinton years.
Good time.
So for vince foster trump,
trump is um,
and all the women that I raped.
How crazy was that when trump brought up
sexual assault victims?
That's hardcore.
I was just like,
dude,
it was right before the debate is why
wasn't playing games?
He was not playing games.
I had told him.
He asked you this because you're a
journalist.
What did you think about the wiki leaks
claim that the young man who was
murdered in Washington dc was the guy
who gave them the info center,
whatever his name was.
You know,
people don't know the story.
He was a young guy who was working for
the dnc.
He was murdered at like 3:00
in the morning or something crazy.
They shot him in the back anD they
didn't take anything from him.
They didn't take his wallet,
his phone,
his,
his cash.
They left everything.
So they called it a robbery,
a robbery tip,
but he was essentially assassinated.
And the investigation is just
nonexistent.
You don't hear a god damn word about it.
I don't know if anybody's like
currently,
you know,
working on it where we don't hear about
it,
but it's not something that's brought up
in the news.
It's just one of those things.
He was killed.
there's no leads and that's it.
It was odd that julian is.
Andre mentioned that as if it was like,
you know,
leading people to think that he was the
leaker.
I don't know.
Well,
that's what he said is essentially his
words to paraphrase were that there are
consequences to giving us information
that's a pretty serious charge.
Basically like he was killed.
He was alive.
If julian assange is a liar,
if that's not true,
that everything he says has to be taken.
You have to take into consideration
everything he says because he's a liar
now because he did.
He really like.
Did he actually come out and say that or
did you kind of insinuate being this guy
was killed and that's let's find out
what's.
Find out what his exact words were.
I'm pretty sure that his words were that
there are consequences for giving
us information.
It's just so crazy when you look at what
that allegation was like,
Russia hacked our election and 52
percent of democratic voters actually
think they hacked the vote when really
it was just pedesta fell for fucking
phishing scam because he's an old idiot.
Yeah,
I used to.
That's what I heard.
Allegedly.
Well,
you know,
that guy is super problematic regardless
of how ridiculous the pizza gate thing
is and what's real,
what's not real,
what is real is it?
Him and his brother were Close friends
with dennis hastert who was the speaker
of the house who was fucking kids for
decades,
fact these in jail for fucking kids.
That was the speaker of the house.
The idea that the speaker of the house
could be a serial child molester and
that's what he is.
I mean,
there's literally with the judge called
him when he sentenced him.
That's insane.
And alan dershowitz,
trump and
clinton were on the lolita express.
Would that billionaire,
that rape plane that had like a bunch of
underage girls?
I mean all of them.
Yeah.
What does that feel?
What does that do?
I mean,
it was just this crazy billing or who
had some island that was known as some
like sex ring and had a bunch of young
kids and all these.
All these dudes were.
We're going there.
Here it goes.
Whistleblowers go through significant
efforts to get us material.
Often very significant risks.
A 27 year old,
the worse for the dnc was shot in the
back murdered just two weeks ago for
unknown reasons as he was walking down
the street and Washington.
So,
and the guy says,
anchor.
That was just a robbery,
not true.
NothIng was robbed.
Says I believe,
wasn't it?
And assad says,
no,
there's no finding.
So,
uh,
and then the anchor says,
what are you suggesting?
What are you suggesting?
He says,
I am suggesting that our sources take
risks and they,
they become concerned to see things
occurring like that.
Huh?
But was he one of your sources?
Sources?
I mean,
the anchor says,
and he says,
we don't comment on who our sources are
and the anchor says,
but why make suggestions about a young
guy being shot in the streets of
Washington?
Assan says,
because we have to understand how high
the stakes are in the United States.
our sources are sources face serious
risks.
That's why they come to us so we can
protect their anonymity.
Hmm.
I found an article about
representational state transfer that
series.
The government is fucking monitoring my
conversation with abby martin.
I just want to say to the government
listened,
you fuCks.
You could just watch the podcast like
everybody else.
You don't have to attack my goddamn
phone.
So that Is really great.
so he's kind of saying it without saying
it.
I don't know why he's doing that.
He also tweeted out some pizza gate
thing,
so I don't know what,
what the deal is.
We all know that,
that that's not.
But here's the thing about the pizzagate
thing is there's a lot of weird shit.
They're like the little international
child molesting symbol was a part of
their logo.
All the weird artwork that that guy.
Okay.
Well,
I,
you know,
I did a whole expose and podesta and he
is a bougie chef so it's not
surprising that he would talk about
pizza as being some like really high
brow chef and they pride themselves on
how they cook all these expensive
dinners and have these dinner parties
and then the spirit cooking thing is
like they're really into this elitist
subversive art scene and so they have.
Yeah,
they have weird ass art and it's really
creepy.
Whatever they do nails when they're
talking about little kids coming over
and getting in the jacuzzi and hanging
out with them.
The kids were going to entertain them.
I mean,
I don't know.
I need a little bit more to,
to really go down that rabbit hole.
Yes,
there's pedophilia.
it's in high places.
The lolita express thing is a really
glaring example,
but in terms of like john podesta been
involved in a,
in a pedophile sex trafficking ring,
I,
I feel like we need a little bit more to
go on because I feel like the what's out
there right now,
it seems pretty self explanatory.
It's like the art and the
the cooking stuff.
I agree with you,
but little kids coming over the house
and getting in the jacuzzi like that
little kids are coming over for
entertainment.
Did you ever read that?
I read the email.
It did and it seemed like they're just
really out of touch with how to talk
about like their child fucking need to
mask it better.
Like I have kids,
I have kids that age and if I'm in the
I'm sending an email to someone else,
you know?
Oh yeah,
you know,
blah blah,
blahs friends are coming over.
Yeah.
I think we're going to have like pizza
or something.
We're going to have a pizza party for
the little ones.
What you just say it like that?
Yeah.
You don't say they're going to come over
and entertain us.
Like what were the exact pull up old
creepy how Alex Jones interpreted that
was saying.
Did he get crazy?
He got super crazy about that email.
About that email specifically being
like,
this is obviously like they're reaping
these kids in the jacuzzi there.
Well,
it is weird.
I don't know what he's saying,
but there's where my favorite thing
about alex is when he freaks out.
Then he say,
apologize.
I'm sorry.
Jump on.
Never swear like that,
but these fucking goddamn goddamn
fucking pizza lovers.
Okay.
We planned to heat the pool,
so a swim as a possibility.
Bonnie will uber service to transport
ruby emerson and mave lasagna,
whatever.
Eleven,
nine and almost seven.
So you'll have some further
entertainment and they will be in that
pool for sure.
What does that mean?
Like why is he bringing kids over his
house?
Oh no man.
The scumbag.
But that's odd.
And did you ever see that thing where a
bright bart had said that many years ago
he made a tweet that was weird.
Super weird,
right?
Like how does,
how does pedesta get away with being a.
What was the exact word?
Forget wofo.
Jamille.
Something about super crazy.
Yeah.
About essentially covering up for kid
fuckers.
Well,
how weird
do you think it is that trump seems to
be the first president or anyone really
in a political
is how progress guru john podesta isn't
a household name as world class under
age,
sex slave op cover,
upper defending unspeakable dregs
escapes
me really heavy in.
This was in february of 2011 before
hastert was arrested,
so this very well could have been
connected by the way.
Hastert only did 15 months for being a
serial child molester.
What band?
And also worked for a bunch of child
molesters that ige,
this internet gaming entertainment
company that just like mind virtual
resources and world of warcraft games
and would sell them and he was like a
money bundler for goldman sachs because
he's a goldman sachs shill and he was
working for like all the people on the
board.
We're just pedophiles.
Really?
Yeah.
I think prince brock was one of the guys
and then one of the guys is still on the
run and has been for the last 10 years,
so where all the pizza gate people
didn't know about it.
Now they did.
I mean,
it's crazy and it's a bowling alley now
it's going to be bowling gate,
but what do you think about trump being
really one of the first people who's won
a political office that has catered to
like the conspiracy crowds and
conspiracy culture and the Alex Jones
crowd and ronald reagan figured out that
if you caught the christian right,
they will vote for you.
I mean there's a.
There's a whole market in that.
It look,
the conspiracy that look,
Alex Jones has a gigantic audience.
Tens of millions people.
People discard him as some crazy
outlier.
He has an audience of tens of millions
of people.
Huge.
He gets as many downloads as the biggest
podcast world probably,
and he's on,
I don't know how many different radio
stations,
but I,
I want to say it's more than a hundred.
He's,
he's got a crazy reach,
so it was a wise move by trump and as
long as he gets on alex's show and
doesn't say anything to fucking crazy
like those people,
like I can't believe the president is
with alex.
You get those people and then you get
the people that don't like alex.
You get those people to.
You get the hardcore republican base who
just want to quote unquote make America
great again and wear red hats.
You get those people to.
Yeah.
This is extremely smart.
That's how went.
I mean,
he's a reality star.
Who won the biggest reality competition
in the world.
You're right.
That's exactly how to put it in.
It was the first time that an actual
popular person entered this popularity
contest.
That's really what,
happily.
Totally.
That's exactly what happened.
And you're right,
he knew how to play the audience.
Bannon knew exactly how to work the
media to,
um,
it's fascinating to,
to cultivate that Alex Jones crowd
because people are analyzing the results
of the election and wondering,
you know,
how do you win?
HoW did he win?
To me,
I feel like that's a huge component that
no one really puts any credit to is that
Alex Jones,
this,
this like voting block that never was
really active before,
like,
other than ron paul will also this
outright thing that we were talking
about.
There's a,
there's,
there's groups of people that were never
interested in politics that are now
treating it the same way they treat
sports.
The these guys are sports fans.
I mean,
that's really what it's like.
It's like,
this is my team.
I'm on team trump,
you know,
and these fucking.
It's like,
yeah,
it's a corp man in and they're showing
up at these berkeley rallies and they're
fighting with people now.
Like now you've got people responding.
This is one of the real problems with
the left,
the real problem with these really
hardcore lefties that are outraged and
want to do something and they want to be
positive so they want to shut down all
these people like milo that the thinker
nazis or ann coulter and all these
people.
But by doing that and by having these
gigantic protest and it literally
shutting down people communicating and
talking.
You invite people to resist that and
then you start these antifa people hit
people in the head with fucking bike
locks.
You see the,
they found that it was a professor that
was hitting people in the head with bike
locks and that this is going to have
people show up and want to hit you with
something and so you can you see now,
and I've seen plenty of footage of trump
protesters and supporters beating other
people out.
It's like getting comfortable on both
sides.
Coming from both sides now,
but I almost feel like this is a
manufactured thing because I think that
there's been from the oakland area and
I've an antifa has been showing up at
every protest for as long as I can
remember and the cops kind of like our
hands off and so I feel like to provoke
the antifa block where you know that
they're like really strategically
oriented and keep going to berkeley and
keep going at berkeley and then making
it like this big free speech blowout
where it's like,
why do you keep going?
And like creating the situation.
You kind of know what's going to happen.
It seems like a manufactured thing and
then at the end of the day it makes the
left easier to demonize and end
Basically protests easier to demonize
where now you have 200 people facing
felony riot charges at the inauguration
protests and a couple of them are just
journalists who are filming and all the
trump people are like,
whatever.
They're fucking writing and they're
fascists in there.
[inaudible].
It's like,
well,
because this happened in berkeley now,
like all protesters are,
you know,
they're scapegoated to these people and
I still get to.
It's easy to box people in,
but I think what's going on at berkeley
is it's the most outrageously liberal
place in the country in berkeley is and
always has been.
Like if you go there.
Exactly.
It's so lefty that it's like it's a
great target.
It's a great place to get things
popping.
So if I was milo or if I was ann coulter
and what is the culture do?
I mean she Wants to sell books.
I mean she's a troll,
she's a troll,
she's totally patrol and we tell them to
be able to rule like probably ashley.
Just one of those,
she's just,
she's a performance artist.
Performance.
Exactly,
exactly.
She's absolutely a performance artist
and not a very good one because if she
was that in trump,
we trust book like the whole cover,
like what in the fuck is that?
I mean it was just bizarre.
Just bizarre that,
that like that she wrote that book.
It was almost like,
okay,
this is cheap.
Even for her,
like this is just like a cheap ploy
during this whole trump movement.
She sees the,
the whole momentum of the country,
so she's going to write a book and
put trump in the title of it.
It's like,
it's so stupid,
but it's weird.
It's just weird that it's so easy,
but it makes sense.
Just like we were talking about how
reagan sort of mobilized the right wing,
conservative people that were christians
that really weren't about politics
before that,
and he kind of brought them in.
People real like they look at it and go,
hey look,
this is an angle.
You know,
there's an angle we can take that no
one's been taking and this you're kind
of like a bait and switch.
This whole mila,
mila berkeley thing becausE they know
exactly what's going to happen when they
go there and then of course that's
exactly what happens and then they can
use it to be like free speech,
free speech.
I mean it just.
Well he knows what he's doing.
Yeah,
it was a clever guy.
He's very clever.
I Mean he knows exactly what he's doing
and you know,
and milo at one point in time,
by the way was a guy who was very anti
hate speech,
you know,
and it was very anti shutting down
people who were writing things to hurt
people.
People have like pulled quotes of his
from the past,
whiCh is intEresting because,
I mean I'm sure peOple's philosophies
changed.
I'm sure mine have and yours have,
but this is like one more piece of
evidence that what you're seeing with a
lot of people that are in the public eye
that are involved in this whole
political arena is you're seeing,
they're working angles.
They're like,
what's the angle like,
okay,
let's go that way and you can justify
it.
Look,
I could justify a lot of different
angles if I wanted to do that,
if I want it to be.
If I wanted to be in an anti trump
protest or an anti free speech poster,
if I wanted to be a person who thinks
that free speech should be limited
because hate speech is not protected by
the constitution.
Like howard dean just said,
that fucking asshole.
He said hate speech is not protected by
the constitution.
The first amendment.
Yeah.
Yes it is.
Howard.
You fucking idiot.
You're a goddamn representative.
Nazi parties exist actually,
and they can have rallies,
you know like that.
That happens in this country when he was
saying it about two,
but it was ridiculous.
Our.
He would.
The way he said it,
it wasn't even like justified.
It wasn't like someone was saying like,
hey,
we need to gather up these gay people
and hang them from stop signs.
That's not what people are saying.
It wasn't anything that extreme where
he.
Oh,
I think it was ann coulter,
I think.
I'm not sure who pulled that up,
see if you can find it.
I'm pretty sure howard dean was talking
about ann coulter and he was saying that
hate speech is not protected by the
first amendment.
So what is he advocating around to?
Roundup angLed his arrest her for.
He's just saying that she should be.
That you can stop her talk.
He just,
you know what?
It was our nuts.
Poorly thought out statement that got
trampled just thrown out and everybody
sort of repeating it over and over and
over again and I just don't think he
thought about it when he was saying it
or the consequences.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Was it about anne culter?
Yes.
It was about hey cultures,
upcoming speech in Vermont,
the Vermont dnc chair,
howard dean,
elaborated on his argument that ann
coulter's upcoming speech at berkeley
does not have to occur because hate
speech in
quotes is not protected by the first
amendment.
Fuck you,
man.
Of course.
Look,
just have someone to bait her.
It's not that goddamn hard her.
It has something to say what we're
saying,
but what about the safe,
the safe space?
like hysteria where people are like,
we need to save spaces,
but then,
but then there it's the same people who
are like,
why are you protesting as like,
let us debate,
well then fucking what is it?
Do you want safe spaces are not they?
Because if you want to have debates or
you want to have speeches,
like you can't Stop people in berkeley
from coming in protesting you,
it's protecting you.
It's such a fundamental idea that we all
know that in order to,
if you're gonna have a discussion with
someone,
you have to let that person established.
This is what debates are about,
right?
let that person establish their position
and then give your counter to that
position.
If this is like so firmly established in
the way we communicate and the way we go
over ideas,
that is essentially the marketplace of
ideas.
You have your idea.
Someone has an opposing idea.
If you don't let that person establish
their idea and you shut it down,
shut it down,
and you throw in rocks and burning cop
cars and throwing bricks through
starbucks.
Windows like you are feeding the whole
resistance to your ideas.
Flames like you're,
you're,
you're feeding the people that are
saying that they're right and you're
wrong because you are against recently
cheating feeding that again.
People sympathize with like Richard
Spencer after he got punched,
you know,
and that's,
that's a problem.
Yeah,
it's a problem because all you have to
do is let those people hang themselves,
give them a rope,
give them broad plenum talk,
but you have to have someone qualified.
You have to have someone who can have
that speech with them and you can't have
the fucking audience shout them down
either.
It's a disservice to both ideas,
both,
but I've heard people say like as
nazi-ism really a an idea worthwhile of
putting it in the marketplace of ideas
like your advocate is genocide.
Okay.
Richard spencer.
So you that guy.
Yeah.
Okay.
But if you are going to have someone
debate them,
you have someone debate them in a venue
where let everyone watch it online.
It's like,
how do you debate someone that wants to
exterminate you?
like if you're like a black person,
you're like,
I'm in a debate.
This guy who,
whose main premise of the argument is
you shouldn't exist.
That's kind of I,
I,
I've,
I've heard people,
it's a,
it's a confusing topic,
but if you don't debate them,
if you don't,
if you shut down their speech,
if you stop and then you can,
they can frame what they were going to
say in a very different way.
They can,
they can gather sympathy with people who
were more pro speech,
more pro free speech than they are anti
what you're saying.
I think that they,
they still are a,
like we were saying before,
nazis still have rallies like no one is
shutting down these from a government
level.
So I think the whole censorship thing is
not relevant to this situation because
that really does mean like the black end
of the state like coming down and
blocking you and instead we have what we
cntf a blocking like physically these,
these venues.
But it's not like these people are
blocked from having venues or access or
speech
platforms.
I mean they're fucking everywhere.
It's like I feel like all over the news,
it's Richard Spencer,
the dapper nazi,
like all these interviews,
aren't these speeches in this one place?
Aren't they very retro like why even do
it that way?
Why have an audience?
Why have an angry mom yelling outside or
even inside like create and cultivate
these situations and they can be the
martyrs,
right?
That free speech,
martyrs.
That's exactly what they're doing.
It's a very poor way to go over ideas
though I think a better way to go over
ideas.
As you have a moderator and two people
in a room together,
you know that that simple one person
isn't a lot of time where they can
express themselves than the other person
has a lot of time where they can counter
and you're not allowed to chime in.
You're not allowed to interrupt.
You're not allowed to in any way disrupt
this person's flow of ideas.
Then there should be a time set aside
where you could Go back and forth with
each other and unless you do it that
way,
you're going to involve the cult of
personality.
You're going to involve the cheers from
the crowds.
You're going to involve all these
different people that can organize to
Sway things one way or another or all
this,
shut it down,
and it's.
It gets as ridiculous as like Jordan
Peterson speeches and I'm sure you've
seen that professor of university of
toronto that doesn't want to use all
these meetup,
gender pronouns.
The 78 now accepted gender pronouns
Canada has really weird laws in Canada.
Has they don't have free speech the way
we have free speech and they have a
human rights council and they've decided
that these 78 or whatever the fuck they
are,
however many they decide on gender
pronouns,
that if you don't use them,
if someone says,
you know,
I want you to call me fox can 26,
but for real,
like if you don't do that,
you're imposing on their human rights.
Other people have debated him and said
that though that's not how it should be
interpreted,
but he's like a very staunch critic of
marxism and he understands the,
the real ideology of marxism and how it
went horribly wrong all throughout the
world,
throughout history,
and that he thinks that what you're
trying to do when you,
when you're invoking like this,
when you're asking the government to
tell people what they must or must not
say,
that you are going down this road,
this very dangerous road of cultural
marxist.
Well,
what does cultural marxism,
because I've heard this said and I
actually have no idea what the hell it
means because marxism is simply a
critique on capitalism,
so I don't understand this whole
cultural marxism like,
well,
let's let's get the dead house has
anything to do with gender pronouns,
but you'd have to talk to peterson about
how it.
But he makes a very compelling argument
about how the two of them are connected.
Essentially what people are trying to do
is control your behavior and they're
just trying to in some way force you to
behave the way they would like you to
behave,
even if it's a preposterous thing,
like making up words and you have to
call them this instead of he,
she or even like even like the people
that want to use they riches know
plurals,
which is fine.
I mean like that's a real word,
you know,
if you want to use it in an incorrect
way and it does get used like,
you know,
uh,
it does use like if anybody wants to use
the bathroom,
they can go ahead.
You can be using that in a singular
term,
you know,
and you,
you're,
it's non gender specific.
So there is like open interpretation in
the stanDard use of it in the english
language.
So pulled up the term cultural marxism
that was looking for.
I can't really find a great definition
for it.
Uh,
it's a couple like the google research
assistants,
a couple of things.
Calling it a conspiracy theory,
the urban dictionary definition.
This isn't like an obvious social
political movement that promotes
unreasoned and irrationality through the
guise of various causes offering
promoted by so called social jet.
This is a perfect example of it.
These causes and their proponents often
are often contradictory and are almost
always never rooted.
in fact indeed true argument or
discussion with proponents of these
causes.
It's almost impossible at most as most
attempts at discourse descend quickly
into shouting name,
calling and chanting slogans.
Well,
that's a perfect otherwise known as the
regressive
left a plate on the contradictory
nature.
I think that this is,
this seems to be like a hub of the alt
right word.
This is founded on like this reactionary
movement on pc culture,
on things like that,
gender pronouns thing,
and it seems like there was no real
political ideology behind what is the
outright other than just a reaction to
this.
like I don't want to conform to this
progressive whatever,
cultural marxism,
but to me I feel like I just.
I don't knoW.
It doesn't bother me as much.
Like what bothers me right now is just
like the empire fucking killing people
on my name.
Trump.
No disgusting war criminal who's flipped
flopped on all the shit that he said
that he said.
That's a different argument,
but you're absolutely right.
That's what I'm saying is these people
are that upset about leftists,
like they think leftists are the problem
and that cultural marxism is like
ruining society and it's like,
what is this government doing?
Like The answer never stopped with when
trump won.
Jordan peterson a,
he's progressive.
He's a liberal.
So this,
I mean the guy who's arguing against
cultural marxism.
Marxism is actually a progressive.
He's actually the liberal.
I mean he's not,
he's not a republican.
He's definitely not outright.
He's canadian.
So they obviously have different parties
up there,
but he's not an alright guy.
He's a professor.
I mean he's not,
he's just sees that there's a bunch of
people on campus that are trying to
control the way other people
communicate.
It'S just such as poor posture.
Yeah,
I,
I totally hear that and I see where
people are really upset about that and
it just,
you know,
I see sj was in leftists are ruining
everything and to me it just seemed like
such an isolated,
like totally inconsequential thing to
what's going on in the rest of the world
and especially what trump is ramming
down everyone's throats.
It's like,
is this really the main issue here?
No,
it's not,
but I agree with you to a certain
extent,
but to not address that or to write it
off,
it empowers
the people that are fighting against it
because this year you're ignoring it.
Like to them it'S a giant issue.
The issue of free speech,
the issue of not having people in force,
whatever ideology that they have on you
that you have to behave the way they
want you to communicate,
they want you to or you're a bigot or
you're a nazi,
like punch a nazi.
Meanwhile you're an actual christian
evangelicals employing top down policy
that's actually telling people,
here's how education's going to be
around here,
so we're going to be indoctrinated.
Like that's what I feel like we're
really missing the boat here.
All these new atheists who agree with
what you're saying,
like don't want to be policed and aRe
more in line with trump.
How come they're not speaking out
against the christian evangelical hold
over this adMinistration?
Well,
which ones are you talking about?
Like,
oh,
I know.
I don't know.
I just kind of said that in the ether,
but I guess I just haven't seen enough
critique of trump for bringing in this
religious fanaticism,
rc.
Nothing.
But I've seen really great.
Maybe it's really good to hear it in
different circles.
That's great.
But um,
people are talking about that.
Well,
what'S weird is that people think that
trump is so inept.
They almost would prefer mike pence and
even ted cruz.
Terrifying,
but it mean who's is it better or worse?
It's like you're not even choosing the
lesser of two evils.
You're choosing in competence versus
this radical right wing christian
ideology that we were terrified of in
the beginning or from the beginning.
It's like ted cruz would have been a
terrible president,
but many people now think he would've
been a better president than Donald
Trump and ted cruz and mike pence would
never have won because they're
disgusting creatures and ted cruz is the
creepiest motherfucker I've ever seen
where he.
He actually tweeted a photo of like a
butterfly cow made out of butter and
said,
and he was like,
my daughter's first word was butter.
It's like,
wow,
you creepy psycho.
So that creepy to you.
That's creepy.
It's weird.
It's just weird.
It's just really in a butter.
Butter is delicious.
It is delicious bread on toast.
He's super fucking weird.
But yeah,
these people would never win without
trump being that conduit to like get in
the white house.
And so I think that with trump not
there,
you don't have this veneer where people
are like,
oh,
trump's really liberal.
Like,
oh no,
he really believes in this stuff.
It's like you would just have pence and
that would be really straightforward of
exactly who pence is and what he
believes in.
Well,
marco rubIo sucks as a debater,
but god damn,
he's an eloquent and really well spoken
man.
OutsIde of those debates.
He just folded under pressure.
He's not good with conflict,
but he's been outstanding.
Yeah,
he's been outstandIng since then.
He just doesn't know how to deal with
that.
That big fucking looming cultive
personality asshole,
and he just doesn't know how to deal
with it.
Trump is such a baby.
He's such a pamper baby.
I saw this chart of um,
how many times,
like,
you know,
this is kind of a stupid thing because
I'm not opposed to like taking vacations
or golfing or whatever,
but the amount that he's gone where he's
just like gone.
Half the weekend.
Maro lago,
like golf.
They Spent $10 so far in the first
hundred days,
trump spent almost as much money as
obama did an entire year on his
vacation.
That's the first one.
Hundred days.
So pampered.
He can't even get away from this world
that he's a part of where he has to go
to a fucking country club and be
surrounded by billionaires.
It's also so incredibly hypocritical
because he was constantly complaining
about obama taking vacations and going
golf and he's golf more than anybody.
You look at the first hundred days of
clinton,
bush,
obama and him.
It's like no one has done this.
I think obama maybe went golfing once in
the first hundred days and trump is like
every week,
four out of seven days.
He's just gone.
It's like,
who's running the country here?
It is weird.
It's crazy.
I just want to finish yesterday or
sunday that he hasn't taken a
international trip yet and at this point
I think George Bush had taken to and
obama taken a too busy at maro lago
international trip for out of the
country to go meet another leader.
Come to make that come to me.
Come play golf.
Come on.
I got a great place.
We have the best,
the best steaks,
the best come back.
We really do.
We really do remember how weird that was
when even have all these props like the
steaks and the manila folders and all
these things like on the magazines and
jet.
He loved all these props,
number that.
No,
he was doing all these campaign rallies
on one one campaign.
Rally had a bunch of trump steaks out on
a table.
I didn't even know trump steaks until
last week.
Was it moshe?
Moshe turned me on to trump steaks.
Moshe is a emotion.
Casher was a show that's on comedy
central right now.
Moshe is a super hardcore lefty.
It's really interesting because he and I
were having this conversation on the
phone last night or texting back and
forth.
He goes,
we were talking about.
He's at.
He asked me to find like a suitable
representative of the alt right come on
his show and sort of talk about these
ideas.
I my poor boy,
who the fuck is a suitable represent
sorry.
Through some people at adam,
every name I threw out and he's like,
oh no,
I know,
but that's what you're asking for it.
He's like,
milo would have been great,
but he's so tainted now.
I'm like,
yeah,
I get it.
Pedophilia is the thing that brought him
down and it was just crazy of all
places.
It's like,
wow.
They did lose three hours.
He got loose,
started talking about what your
reaction.
Your reaction was really fun in that
too.
You're like,
that sounds like.
Well,
he was trying to justify his own,
his own victimization.
He was molested as a child.
Was trying to turn around and say that
he was.
He said,
I was the predator.
Don't get it wrong.
He's basically trying to empower
himself.
He was fucked by a priest when he was
13.
I mean this is the reality of his life.
That is terrible.
And he's trying to figure out a way
where that empowers him and I just find
it interesting like the tommy lauren
thing was fired because she was pro
choice.
It's like that went too far for the
blaze.
Know,
like the pedophilia things too far for,
for the outright.
Right.
I was thinking that about hillary
clinton.
How crazy would it be if chelsea clinton
went to work for the blaze?
Oh god.
If she started,
she started going super hardcore.
Right?
And she's got two flags,
motorcycle jacket on,
pearly whites.
The hedges.
Go interrupt those.
Antiwar demonstrations.
Again,
chelsea,
just like you used to be a nightmare.
I mean this,
what do you think about the Syria thing
though?
Trump within two days of the chemical
weapons attack,
he's already bombing assad and that was
a big point of contention.
I know with the Alex Jones communiTy
with the alt right.
I think a lot of them were anti
intervention because that's what he was
saying and so what is,
what do you think is going on?
Because you have that whole argument
where like,
oh,
all these people are pulling them in
different directions.
He doesn't really want to do this.
What do you think?
Well,
I think he's incredibly impulsive.
I mean that's sort of been established
that he's very impulsive.
So I also think that he's got this
desire to be a strong leader and to be a
guy who make strong decisions and it's
not going to take any bullshit,
you know?
And I worry about that.
That scares the shit out of me because
when you really find out how much the
power the president has in terms of like
launching a nuclear strike and then you
look at the conflict that we're getting
into with North Korea,
it's entirely possible.
I mean,
they are moving nuclear submarines right
now as we speak off the coast of North
Korea.
That is happening right now as we speak.
It was.
They were talking about it today.
It's in the news right now.
This is terrifying because if they
decide to launch a warhead at North
Korea,
the odds of someone retaliating are so
fucking high and if they do retaliate,
it's probably going to be los angeles.
It's probably going to be.
We're the closest.
We're the closest to North Korea and
we're also the closest.
I guess we would be the target for
China.
I guess we would be the target for a lot
of places.
Yeah.
Let's talk about this North Korea thing
really quickly because the media is
painting it like North Korea,
like we're going to strike back really
when North Korea is repeatedly said,
we will never striked the us ever.
Will never strike anyone unless we're
attacked.
What are they doing that we're so
intense with them right now?
They are doing missile,
missile tests.
They don't even work.
They tried to missile and it blew up
that.
But that's how crazy the us has.
And we have historical amnesia where
americans don't know geography until we
bombed somewhere.
Right?
So we have completely no memory about
the korean war where theu ,
s military invaded North Korea and
bombed napalm the fuck out of the
country for three years.
Killed Twenty percent of the population
killed three to 5 million people left
the country.
We just completely forgot.
North koreans haven't forgotten.
They haven't forgotten.
They have a deep seated hatred for the
us for a good reason.
Um,
and americans have no idea.
We probably don't even know what that we
went to war with Korea that they don't
even think about.
Why is there a north and South Korea?
Like,
what the fuCk is this?
You know,
it's so kim,
jon,
uhm,
obviously probably what he's learned by
now in terms of us empire,
imperialism and interventions is that
you have to not only act like,
you will use nukes,
like you have to have nukes and you have
to act like you will use them if you get
attacked,
unless you want to get invaded.
Look what happened with gaddafi,
saddam,
all these things.
Assad,
you give up your chemical weapons and
then it doesn't matter.
Well,
I'm,
I'm terrified.
I'm terrified of this whole North Korea
conflict.
As I think everybody is.
It's,
it's a terrifying place first of all
because it's one of the last really
obvious military dictatorships in this
country,
in the world rather.
There's not a whole lot of them left,
but that's one of the last one since one
of the ones that's like,
you can see it.
There are so extreme.
They see them goosestepping walking down
the street.
You see the people wailing in agony.
When kim jong il died,
like it's,
it's a very,
very strange world where people are born
in prison and they live as prisoners
their whole life.
And some of them as escaped and detailed
the horrors of the prisons and what's
going on with that worries me is because
it won't be hard to sell.
Exactly.
Yeah.
People already are like,
of course in North Korea is horrible.
That prison camps,
labor camps is undeniable.
So like,
yeah,
I guess we should just do regime change.
That's what I was going to get to is
what you had said before the podcast
started,
that it's a massive reserve of minerals
in North Korea and this is what you and
I were talking about,
conflict minerals and phones before the
podcast started and that they know that
this,
by the way also Afghanistan,
trillions of dollars of minute minerals
in Afghanistan,
conflict minerals.
Absolutely.
We're still fucking there.
To be honest,
16 years later we dropped that mother of
all bombs that,
that like dick measuring contest that
trump just laid his dick out on the
table and was like,
oh no,
drop this giant fucking bomb,
dusted off from the shelf.
It's been sitting there.
Bush wasn't even crazy enough to use it
and all of a sudden people are like,
wait,
we're still in Afghanistan and isis is
no one.
No one asks any questions.
Why is isis there?
Why are we still in Afghanistan?
Everyone's like,
oh,
cool.
Another one.
Let me see.
Let me see the video.
Lindsey graham's like,
oh cool.
Boom.
It's disgusting,
dude.
I mean there was 95,000,
I think 100,000
people who lived in the and district
like this was a.
This wasn't just a mountain region with
goats.
I mean there are people there.
The way that afghans are dehumanized and
the way that the media cheered on the
Syria strike and this moab thing makes
me fucking sick.
Brian williams is sitting up there
quoting leonard cohen.
He was like,
they're beautiful.
The bombs are beautiful.
He said it to me.
He said,
I'm bunch of times.
It was amazing in like 30 seconds.
It was weird.
It was sick.
It's almost like he's trying to make up
for the fact that he lied about being in
that helicopter,
trying really hard to make up for us.
Like look,
just you just gotta go hardcore,
right?
Just go all the way.
Just talk about how beautiful it is.
And it was like.
And then fareed zakaria here they are
telling
us that trump is mentally unfit.
Puppet of Russia,
who's retarded yet the second he starts
bombing,
it's like,
oh,
love it.
First strike.
Like he started bombing assad now.
We all love him.
Rachel maddow has been talking the last
30 days or three months,
six months about how he needs to be
impeached.
He's guided by putin and then the second
he started bombing Syria.
Oh,
it becomes a commercial for tomahawk
missiles.
Rachel maddow did a 30 minute segment
just analyzing how efficient tomahawk
missiles are.
Well,
great.
Why do you think she did that?
I think that the.
There's a bipartisan establishment
consensus on foreign policy and there
has been.
This is the empire,
does the corporate media.
I'm completely loves the empire.
They love imperialism,
they love selling wars.
They have for a long time,
joe.
That's how I became a journalist because
I saw the Iraq war been sold by quote
leftists are liberals on tv and I just
couldn't understand why they were
selling a completely insane,
unnecessarily illegal war where there
was a lot of it.
well,
there were selling it or at least in
support of it because we were really
terrified after nine slash 11,
so after nine slash 11,
there was this movement to do something
and this massive amount of people that
ordinarily would have a lot of distrust
towards the right.
They all of a sudden we're trusting in
bush and trusting in the government to
go and out adequate job.
So it'd be a stenographer because you're
scared.
That's like the time that you're
supposed to step up and say,
okay,
I need to question my government's
claims because we're in such a state of
hysteria and acquiescence that I need to
as a journalist.
QuesTion authority question my
government.
That's the number one job that you have.
What was your thought?
How old will.
You're not old enough,
really?
How old were you at September 11th.
Oh yeah,
no,
I was 18,
so I was.
What did you have any.
Obviously when you're 18 it's hard to
formulate.
Yeah,
no,
I'm my eye.
I was stunned.
I mean I agreed with the Afghanistan war
at the time beCause I didn't really know
and then I went into college and learned
about what the fuck this government and
country has been doing to the rest of
the world and what militarism and empire
has been doing.
So I kind of put it together and then.
But that was just Afghanistan.
I really woke up when one day my mom
called me and she was like,
did saddam bama us?
She said because every single media
outlet has just switched over from
Afghanistan to Iraq unquestioningly.
So do you think that like rachel maddow
for me always seems like if there's
anybody that's not toeing the line,
it's that lesbian but it doesn't seem
like she would be like,
I like,
she'd be like the perfect person to sell
you some shit that you know,
like you would never buy as a person on
the left because she's like,
she's super articulate.
She's wicked sMart and she's obviously a
lesbian and she's got short hair and she
hated trump,
so like if you wanted to sell something,
she's your huckleberry
and she was trying to sell that Russia
shit real hard.
I mean she talked more about Russia than
any other issue and that's the Problem
with this so called resistance is that
when you focus on a fake issue like
Russia usurping trump's brain or like
and trump's and puppeting
him,
then you forget about all the rapid fire
executive orders he's throwing down you.
You aren't focusing on the real
important things that he's doing that we
could actually galvanize and stop and
especially when you're just pro war,
these motherfuckers are,
they're funded by defense contractors in
banks.
That's what the corporate media is.
She knows gone all in that.
It's been like a coup against Russia.
What's homeboy's name that used to be on
espn?
The fuck.
Oh my god.
Keith olbermann.
The reason you saw,
did you see the kermit the frog where
he's like covered in the american flag?
Did you see that crazy way?
We should look that way.
He's got a whole thing.
It looks like he's in a basement
somewhere.
Nicer resistance.
Sponsored by gq.
What is going on with him?
does he have children?
I don't know what the hell is going on
with the kids.
I used to.
I used to really,
really like him.
Psychologically.
I used to as well.
I used to think that he had some
interesting rants.
The problem is too many people liked it
and then he like got drunk with it seems
like now he's,
he's his,
his speeches are,
they're almost like a parody of a guy
who is.
It's almost likE an old Christian Slater
movie about a guy who's got like some
sort of a ham radio thing and he's
fighting against the oppressive
government.
It's really,
really hurt tuna fish.
Yes.
cartoonish is the right word.
Really weird.
I saw this one like side by side,
meme of him draPed in the american flag
and he's like this,
you know,
on the cover of gq.
And then someone put kermit the frog,
like draped in a magazine.
This is what keith olbermann thinks he
looks like and this is what he really
looks like and it was just like a little
frog into.
It's just nuts.
I mean,
what the hell is this guy doing and how,
what is gq doing?
IT's like you have teen vogue somehow
leading the resistance and like what the
fuck country.
His videos are so strange.
There's so verBose and it's like,
damn,
that dude.
Is this a first draft?
It's like,
it is.
It seems like you've got a lot of extra
words in there.
We could,
you could trim that down a little bit
and have a little more impact.
But I wait,
I wrote this down because I wanted to
say this.
This is insane.
So the pentagon just came out with a
number.
It said 70,000
people have been killed as a result of
bombing Syria in Iraq since 2014.
You're like,
okay,
that's crazy.
Um,
they said they called the militants.
We already know that militant can be
just a military age males.
So really they include the libyan
militant feminist feminists.
You can build short hair,
you know,
lesbian on the,
on the ground and they think they were a
man.
So They include like anyone who's
probably over the age of 10 and a male
as a militant.
So anyway,
these numbers are 70,000
people are killed.
And then they said only 229 civilians
were killed.
So 70,000
militants,
229 civilians.
Here's another interesting part.
The cia in 2014,
estimated that there are only between 30
to 40,000
isis fighters in Syria and Iraq.
So are The.
So I'm sorry,
what the fuck did these other 30,000
people come from and did you kill all
isis?
Like all isis has gone somehow their
back because they're still staring.
What year was the estimate?
Two thousand 14 is when they said there
were probably 30 to 40,000
and then the pentagon just came out and
this is according to the la times 70,000
militants killed since 2014.
Only tWo hundred civilians.
Don't worry about it.
Wow.
That makes me feel really good.
I've never seen one tear.
I feel pretty good.
Just killing a bunch of terrorists.
Wow.
THat's nuts.
Yeah.
No one questions.
This shit man.
It's sick.
You will.
I watch house of cards,
so I have a really good grasp of the
political system.
Is the new sis a season out yet?
Not yet.
Next month.
I'm still on the.
I just started.
I just started this year,
so yeah,
I binge watched.
I went from the 2012 episodes all the
way to.
I'm on season four right now.
God damn it.
I was watching when it became really
like all about the potent character
because you know,
first frank underwood's like he kills
the journal.
Robin white.
They're bitches.
Bad ass though.
I'll tell you why she.
She directs some of the best episodes to
really?
Yeah.
She directed.
When I watched last night,
I was like,
jesus,
creepy camera angles and they remind me
of the clintons.
Oh,
for sure.
I thought it should be.
It should have been illegal for hillary
to even run.
Yeah,
because I,
I look at them as a unit just like the
underwoods,
you know,
and they work together where clinton
even admitted that hillary was the one
who sold the yugoslavia bombing and
stuff and she even said,
she was like,
I'm an appoint build to run the economy.
It's like again,
destroyed the economy back in the
nineties.
How is this legal?
My favorite footage of her of all time,
where you really got to See behind the
wizard's curtain was when kadafi died.
That was sick when she was literally
back her head laughing,
going,
we came,
we saw he died after he was raped by a
bayonet from the rebels that we funded
and you could watch it like you could
see stabbed in the asshole.
You can watch him,
you could watch him terrified and he
doesn't even react.
He's so fucked up.
And then they're shooting them and
killing them.
They tried them around his dead body.
It's fucked up.
But watching that guy shoved that band
at up to up his ass.
It's like,
whoa.
And what was the premIse of the Libya
thing?
Now it's a completely failed state.
Isis has totally taken over the country
and where all the interventionists that
were cheering on the Libya bombing and
they all said gaddafi was on the verge
of committing to massacre and ben gazi
and we have to go in.
We have to do the no fly zone.
Where all these people now.
Where are these cheerleaders now?
Yeah,
just kind of a twitter message argument
in Syria from a guy who lives in Libya.
It was pretty deep.
What did he say?
Just terrified.
He wants to talk about it.
Just would love to be a guest on the
podcast to the.
I think the.
The idea that you're going to remove a
dictator and then everything's going to
be fun is so crazy and so it's never
worked ever.
It'll work in Syria.
How navy.
What do you do?
Like what do you do?
If I can fucking do anything you to lead
those people suffer when the police
officers of the world,
when has any humanitarian intervention
resulteD in anything?
Good.
can you tell me?
That's a good question.
It's always killed more people than
we're trying to save.
Well,
trump bombed Syria because kids were
gassed and in the meantime killed kids
when he was bombing them.
Germany now makes great cars and they
used to make nazis.
So have you heard the norm mcdonald?
A bit about.
Oh man,
he has the best.
Like nazi jokes.
No.
So good.
It was so crazy to have all the head of
all the comedians.
He really pulls it off.
What is a duty?
We have to watch it.
What is it that there's a reason?
I mean,
he's done a million.
Norm is so crazy.
Nuts.
He's such a character.
He's so great.
he's always wearing like a letterman
jacket and it's like,
what the nuts.
That's who he is to,
you know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't even drive.
Oh yeah.
He's scared of driving.
So weird.
I flew with him randomly twice.
Just randomly.
Just like totally total dumb luck on two
separate occasions as norm set right
next to me and he's like a tree.
Can't believe this is happening.
Yeah,
it was.
The last one was hilarious.
We have this long conversation.
We having a great old time and he's
telling me,
yeah,
I quit smoking,
I don't like to smoke anymore.
It's just terrible.
So hard to quit,
but I'm glad it did.
We land and he immediately walks right
into a gift shop or buy cigarettes,
so I changed my mind.
I want to start smoking again and he's
lighting before he gets out the door,
but he's so impulsive.
He's like walking towards doing.
I'm like,
whoa,
like norm,
what are you doing?
He goes,
yeah,
I guess I smoke again.
There's people out there that are like
pretending to be wacky.
Right.
He's really wacky.
I love those people.
There's so.
There's so few of them who are just
themselves like no matter what,
just that's who norman is.
He's great and he's so funny.
David cross's new specials.
Really good.
Actually,
it's not new.
It was before trump got elected,
but it's hysterical.
His stuff on gun control is really,
really funny and he's doing it to like a
houston audience where it's a lot of
trump supporters and he just goes balls
to the wall,
like everyone's walking out.
Really just.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
Houston is a strange place because it's
all.
There's a lot of liberals in houston,
a lot more than houston is way more
diversified than it gets credit for.
It's a very interesting city.
It's very interesting.
I feel like dallas,
austin,
austin is the super lefty part.
That's the most lefty part of Texas,
but houston is way more cut down the
middle.
It's almost like it's a
split of austin and dallas and it's like
you got the cool.
Yeah.
You got.
I love houston.
You got austin left dallas pretty right,
and then you've got houston,
which is like a combo plate bit.
I mean,
do you have any.
Trump will get mad.
People fucking attacked him and I made
videos of people getting attacked for
st.
How are you not making fun of trump?
It's Donald Trump.
Well,
they'll get it.
They'll get it.
Eventually it will take a little time.
I mean when there's no way.
Snowflakes.
Yeah.
There's no way this is going to keep
going and be good.
It's just.
I really think,
and this is what I think,
and I don't think this is necessarily a
reflection of who Donald Trump is or I
just think the idea of a president is
preposterous.
The idea of one person that has that
much power over hundreds of millions of
people is insane.
It's an idea that was created back when
people rode horses and roping with
feathers.
They used to.
They used to fucking.
I mean,
that's really what it was.
the whole representative government,
you have a representative government
because some people lived in North
Dakota and how the fuck would you get
worried to Washington?
Well,
you had to have somebody talking for
you.
Well now you can send an email.
You fuck.
You could vote online.
The idea is antiquated.
It's so behind the times and it's so
behind the times to have one person have
any sort of massive power and also I
feel like the government works very hard
to stop monopolies in certain sectors.
Why don't they work so hard to stop it
in government because this left versus
right.
This republican versus democrat thing is
a goddamn ruse.
Appropriations police themselves,
great question.
It's people.
It's like I think scholars,
educators,
people who actually understand the
consequences of these ideological
structures that were trapped in these,
these,
these are structures left versus right
as a structure because they provide you
with a predetermined pattern or behavior
that you adopt and there's many,
many easily influenced people that go
super hardcore,
right or super hardcore left because
they want social brownie points within
the structure and that's a natural part
of being a human.
It's a natural part of tribal behavior
and it has to be addressed and it has to
be addressed openly and it has to be
addressed from a an understanding of
fundamental understanding about a way
the human mind works and the way the
human psychology works and our need for
social acceptance works.
There's a lot of the way we behave
that's just based on and predicated on
these really simple,
obvious principles that everybody knows.
Peer pressure,
the desire to be loved.
Those things all play a massive part in
how you're manipulated and how you
manipulate yourself.
You convince yourself of certain things.
I really firmly believe that when you go
super hard,
right and super hard left,
the distance between these two is not
nearly
as far as you think and that the
ideological point of views than the what
they want and what they're trying to
accomplish is very different,
but the way they think,
the way they've locked themselves into
these predetermined thought patterns,
they're not much different.
They're just were indoctrinated one way
or indoctrinated or another way they
might have gone through the church
system or they might've gone through the
university system,
but they've sort of both taken these
hard line stances.
Whereas the reality of the world and
have most reasonable people is there's a
lot of weirdness and there's a lot of
variables to be considered in.
Most people are not hard.
Right and most people are not hard left
theirs and you have to take one or the
other and it's really the best way is
probably a gigantic group that gets to
decide on all sorts of different things
and many,
many different parties to choose from.
Like I think holland has something like
don't they have like 16 different
political parties or something that we
have this two party dictatorship and I
was reading this quote from chris hedges
that really says it all.
It's like exactly what you're saying
right now.
You have conservatives across the
country who are worried about abortion
and obsessing about these issues and
then you have the liberals in New York
who are obsessing about creationism in
schools.
Meanwhile,
goldman sachs continues to fucking win.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter what you guys are
squabbling about on the ground,
left,
right?
Liberal,
conservative,
like these people are in power and
they're going to further entrench their
power.
We're all the losers here and it's.
Yeah,
like you were just saying.
I mean why do we have a system that
props up these two parties that going
back to the corporate media,
continues to sell war after war
continues to just sell off our
government to corporations.
It's just the matter of which they do so
well.
Control of groups.
Anytime you have one person or one
organization that has control over a
group,
whether it's a dictatorship,
whether it's a government,
so like what,
what is a government for?
is it to control groups of people or is
it to provide people with services like
schools and utilities and infrastructure
that should be like really what it is
and the idea that war is an extra bowl.
It's an extra bowl.
You can't remove it from our culture.
You cannot.
I mean if you ask people,
do you envision a time in your life or
war doesn't exist?
No one says yes,
but yet sad is it's crazy.
It's crazy.
We just live in a war economy or that's
just a necessity.
It's like,
well,
we have to have just endless war.
Right?
What is that?
Is that the disconnection between human
beings based on financial,
financial situations,
based on language,
based on culture,
based on religion,
like all these differences are so vast
that we have to launch bombs out of
planes.
I mean it's an indoctrination of
american exceptionalism.
going back to the historical amnesia
about what this government has done.
The rest of the world hasn't forgotten.
The rest of the world is very acutely
aware of what the empire does on a daily
basis.
We have no idea.
Right.
But it's every country.
I mean it's every country with the
military tries to enforce that military
in some way,
shape or form on other countries.
I mean it's just,
it's gone on since the beginning of time
as far as people getting together in
groups and then going over and
conquering other people that have
resources.
Well,
some people would say it's the,
it's the system,
the economic system that once you
control one area,
you have to move capital and it and
extract capital from other areas through
force,
through military force,
and that's the extension of imperialism
through capitalism.
And then so you just go and now we're
the biggest,
most powerful empire controlling the
entire world and we have to go after the
last remaining sovereign quote unquote
sovereign states to completely control.
I mean,
yes,
other countries have done that before,
but never on the level of what we're
doing.
If we could just get everybody to speak
english and everybody to listen to us,
we will be fine.
We need to do is wipe out all the other
cultures when you use a wipe wipe out
all of them.
We need cultural marxism.
We just need a dictatorship.
A one trump world.
I was going to ask you,
how do you feel about the.
I feel like the level of discourse has
gotten to the point back to the
reactionary thing someone was telling me
this last night,
that the word responsibility,
it's like you know,
your ability to respond,
the ability to understand a situation
responded,
not just react and I feel like so much
of our culture is just reacting to news
without even understanding what the hell
is going on.
You know the,
the twitter universe where it's just
like you'd see something and you react
and what?
What does that do to critical thinking?
What does that do to discourse when you
do not understand issues or have the
ability to respond that responsibility?
Well,
not only that,
you be aged and dated by so much data.
If you look at something,
you're looking at a headline really
quick.
So many people have no idea what the
article even says like we did like I did
about that epa or you want me to hear
that shit and you could be at a gas
station right now talking to her friend.
Remember that fucking government for
shutting down database with the epa
can't even get a hold of the
information.
That's it's crazy.
We got to organize mean while you're not
even reading.
I didn't read it.
I just told you about it.
I had jamie pull it up and then we found
out if it wasn't for jamie pulling it
up,
I would probably pair it out for a
couple of days.
Something would have had to.
Somebody would have had to tell me on
twitter,
hey matt,
it's a hoax.
I would have.
Otherwise she tweeted it,
shit,
it's a hoax.
There's too much coming at us.
Abby.
It was too much.
We can't handle it.
It's totally true.
It's too much info and totally true.
It's part of the whole thing with the
internet is like these little 140
characters.
Sound bites,
you getting off twitter,
but then the fact that it's coming at
you from websites,
it's coming at you from facebook,
it's coming at you from instagram.
It's just coming at you in a way that
like there's no fucking way you can keep
up with all this.
There's no way,
and that's part of what's going
on with people.
Absolutely,
and so there's.
There's a,
an embracing of anti-intellectualism
that you're seeing now that I think is a
response to that.
I think people are scared and one of the
things they're trying to do when people
are scared,
they do a couple things.
One thing they do is flatter.
There's little of that longing from back
when they thought the earth was flat,
flat.
I get more fucking angry people online
because of flat earth than anything I've
ever done other than make fun of vegans.
I think no way.
Fluttered.
There's an angry that you don't grow mad
really?
So everyday I get called the shill
everyday.
I'm around earth shell and they tell me,
this is where it gets really hilarious.
Your checks were being cashed,
bro.
I'm getting.
I'm getting round earth shield checks.
I get them in the mail was george soros.
George soros sends me $3 a month and
I've been open about it $3 every month
to promote the idea that the earth is
round for the less than the price of a
grand day.
Starbucks coffee.
I am willing to protest checks,
man.
Got to get a protest chest.
it's so good.
So good.
Especially if you could send it to eat
it like a whale sandwich.
You'll spend your money on something
terrible.
You get that protest money and you spend
it on something horrible to balance it
out.
You've been to Iceland,
right?
No.
Awesome.
It is amazing,
but want to go just for the northern
lights are so bad.
the food's so bad because they only like
whale horse while they have this pickle.
This fermented shark supposed to be the
fouls thing on earth and they love it.
It's almost kind of like the moon where
you're like,
there's not even insects here,
so you understand why.
Why do people live here bringing their
stuff in boxes and barges and shit.
Look,
we have a plant before it spoils.
They seemed like really cool people
don't make it grow.
Giants like they have a disproportionate
number of like strong man winters that
come from Iceland.
Yeah,
vice did a whole thing on them.
They're fucking.
He's enormous.
Viking dogs that live up there.
I know they filmed the son of the,
of the game of thrones up there.
It's,
it's stunning.
I mean it really does feel like a
different planet.
Isn't the mountain from there?
The fucking guy who plays the mountain,
that enormous strong man.
He's like the world's strongest man.
The mountain and game of thrones.
That guy was switched.
That dude's head.
You have to close your eyes.
One I didn't say who he was in st.
There's one.
Really?
Yeah,
it's awesome.
See,
that's a good scene,
but it's one of those.
Whoa.
That's one of the things I really love
about television now.
It's like people just fucking die like
people that you really like,
they die,
you know?
I mean sometimes it's great.
Sometimes it's like when they killed
glen with A baseball bat on walking
dead.
I was like,
yeah,
his bulging out of his skull right here.
That's where I cut it off.
Absolutely.
This is a zombie show anymore torture
show really as torture.
Porn and the zombies are
inconsequential.
Yup.
All of a sudden they're not scary like
everyone just push them away and keep
running and it's seven episodes of just
dialogue of them walking around and it's
like,
dude,
just compact this rogue one.
I loved the new star wars movie,
but everyone dies.
Spoiler spoiler.
Spoiled the fuck out of it.
But I didn't.
I didn't see it.
I want to see it.
It just didn't.
I'll tell you what I'm holding my breath
for everyday.
Life is downtime until the new alien
movie comes out and does it create new
alien,
May 19th,
jesus christ to ad looks awesome.
Ad for it.
No.
Oh,
let's play the trailer and the trailer.
Jamie.
I haven't seen the arrival of the trip.
They're not going to get mad at us.
We'll.
Yeah,
they'll take it off.
Take it off.
We'll play it afterwards.
Sits.
It's so weird.
YoU know,
I had a conversation with somebody about
this.
If you guys react to it,
we mIght be able to play it.
So when we talked about,
okay,
well listen folks,
we're just trying to sell your goddamn
movie.
I'm a huge fan of those and I think this
is this and this.
It's not going to be ridley,
ridley scott.
I think it is really.
I think this is really solid returns.
She should know.
I think it's a pretty cool thing.
She isn't enrolled.
I think that's the idea,
but that was prometheus's a prequel to
write.
I never thought it wasn't good.
it was to cgi.
I was like,
that's not a real dude.
That's why star wars is so good because
they finally bring back the cost.
It's great.
It's.
It's not a lot of cgi,
cgi,
a lot of star wars.
Oh,
you're a woman and a fucking chinese
transgender person.
Like people.
Here it is.
Here's the official trailer.
Go full screen.
I'm just happy jar jar binks is out of
the picture.
Sucks.
So you know what's fucked up.
They like the old school man alien from
the original one.
The computers looked so clunky.
I know what they thought were going to
have for computers and what's his face
here?
Mcbride?
Yeah.
Danny mcbride.
Wow.
Look at kenny powers.
Isn't it so great.
I've never seen him play a serious role.
It's just looks so bad.
This is nuts.
Yeah.
I don't know where they filmed it.
They filmed a lot of shit in New
Zealand.
that's where they did the hobbit.
New Zealand is one place that I really
need to go.
I keep hearing how amazing it is,
but yeah,
this looks good.
No burns,
no animals.
It's like Iceland bitch.
That's Montana.
Okay.
Don't be so fucking willing to see
animals on the planet where you don't
know what can eat shit.
Damn.
Shit's food.
This is so cool.
So it's like an a planet where the
aliens are populated planet team of
people that are going to go save human
or something like that.
Imagine you get paid to repopulate a
planet.
Sorry.
We have to fuck to fuck for the future.
They don't know good.
Don't get too close to it.
Have you not seen these motherfuckers?
I haven't seen nothing,
but I just love when they do a movie
like this and now they have these modern
special effects.
Totally.
But they abused those things sometimes.
One of the coolest things about the
original alien was you saw very little
of it.
Exactly.
That's the problem with all movies and
tv now is you just see way too much.
There's no buildup.
Well,
it's also a real fear comes from the
unknown.
exactly.
You know,
and glimpses like american werewolf in
london.
You only saw like a couple of titling
flashes.
Totally.
And it was awesome.
Whereas Stephen King movie called the
laying of layers.
It was.
I was so terrified.
I can't remember the last time I was
watching a movie that I was so scared
and terrified.
And then at the very end,
cgi like must've just come out.
They show that lear and it's like,
it looks just like this.
It's like a black spot on the,
on the screen here is the alien.
The book is great.
Oh,
it's so good.
Show what the actual can see the little
guys up there and go,
wow,
that's what it looks like.
That's so stupid.
That's sad and it was creepy.
You get killed by.
Look at it is that they really fly
because he can't be real.
Is real real?
Was that a made for tv movie though?
That's probably why I didn't have any
money.
And plus people that watch tv they feel
like are still would have been better to
have just like little puppets on a
string though,
but that would suck.
Like if minions really killed you,
like from despicable me.
I felt the most like forced cultural
thing I've ever seen the minion ad
campaign here.
It's because you don't have kids.
It wasn't really popular kids.
It was my kids love that.
it makes sense.
They love it.
I thought it was just some weird forced
on adults thing.
Like you're going to love minions shit.
I fucking love.
And then like you get it.
Oh that's right.
It's coming out.
So no,
we did it.
Yeah.
You haven't seen it.
I just tried to watch it and it was like
I as six hours hours artists and artists
one,
but the new one day they've shown it.
It looks way creepier.
It used to be to look creepier than used
to be the picture show guy.
Right.
It was it.
Tim,
what thE fuck's his name?
Was it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
The one from the tv series.
Well that was extremely scary.
So that is that guy.
But there's some creePy images of it
like where you see his teeth and shit.
But uh,
yeah,
it was.
What's his face from rocky horror?
What the hell's his name?
I've never seen rocky horror picture
show.
It's one of those.
Yeah.
The time just to take tim curry.
Tim curry was the original it.
He was the original clown.
That's another great book.
See,
I feel like stephen king's movies all
suck bad ones for sure.
Not that they suck.
I love Stephen King,
but his books are so good that the books
just don't.
You just can't turn it into a movie.
And like,
like pet cemetery was so god damn creepy
as a book.
And then you see the movie like,
oh,
the cat's going to kill me.
I'll fucking kill that cat.
Let me get ahold of that care.
If it's a demon.
Katelyn grabbed by stupid little head.
I'm really excited for dark tower are
both steven.
Oh cool.
But stand by.
We're not superstitious or supernatural
force or I think when he green mile as
well,
there was like a little bit of
supernatural share with Michael Clarke
duncan,
but the thing is like when you turn his
movies into something that you have to
look at,
like christine,
they kind of pulled augustine as just
the car,
but it was even creepier in the book and
then you get more,
you know,
you get more insight into the guy who
created the car,
was sold him the car.
Super descriptive with his language and
it really paints a picture that you can
never do justice when you're watching
it.
Well,
I'm excited for the dark tower series
though,
but do you know that the shining was
very different than the book?
I read the book.
The book's very different and he redid
the movie with his blessing and they use
the guy from wings that a made for tv.
She was In it.
I think tears.
The bartender didn't work,
but kubrick kubrick had a lot of weird
shit in the shining,
like there's a lot of references to the
apollo moon landings as long as hidden
shit in there hook story that said that
he had like proven that the moon landing
was false or whatever.
Well,
he definitely did a bunch of shit in the
shining to pay homage to the apollo moon
missions and some sort of a weird way.
Like there was a.
I forget,
there was a bunch of different things
that were there.
First of all,
the little boy wore a rocket.
He wore look at apollo rocket sweater
and then there was the number for one of
the rooms that was the exact distance
between the earth and the moon and
there's a whole documentary that goes
over in depth.
The connections that kubrick made
between the shining and the apollo moon
missions.
It's fucking pretty intense stuff.
Awesome.
Yeah,
and it was just a.
It was a different book though.
The book,
the book was a slow build before
jackets.
Crazy.
And then in the movie Jack Nicholson was
like crazy already.
He was like a little crazy and then it
just got crazy and crazier.
Whereas in the book he like slowly
became more and more nutty and you
bought into it like you saw him like
getting taken by this crazy hotel and so
he didn't like cooper x interpretation
and that the,
no,
he didn't like,
he didn't like that apparently.
Which is too bad because it just,
he just can't make a book into a movie,
you know,
like he,
I guess he can but they're just not as
good.
You know?
I hate people that say that though I'm
saying it and I hate people that say
that the book is the book we don't read
anymore.
I think people will read.
I hardly read anymore.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I listened to books on tape,
hardly sit down and read them.
I still read them a little bit,
but I enjoy having someone read for me.
That's awesome.
But it feels like a fraud.
Like when I say if I tell someone I read
a book,
I have to read some of the book to say I
read the book right?
Like,
but I'll read part of it and they'll go
book on tape and then I go,
I read that book,
but I didn't really read it.
I only read like three chapters and the
other 11 that had some actor read if you
tell.
But if you tell somebody,
yeah,
I listen to a lot of books on tape.
Like,
oh,
you fucking moron.
But no one's tried to have you write a
book yet.
Oh yeah.
I had a book deal and it was so brutal.
Talk to the editor was so brutal.
I gave them their money back.
What was the book about?
Just short a bunch of essays on things,
but they wanted,
this is what they asked me to do.
They asked me to transcribe my standup
once they were like,
they read some of my writing because I
used to do a lot of blogs and I used to
put a lot of blogs on my website and I
put them on online and some other
venues.
And um,
they were like,
hey,
we want to give you a book deal and
what's just write whatever you want to
watch.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then once you get some money from
them,
then it's like,
we want you to write what we want you to
write.
And then they wanted me to write the.
One of the thoughts was they wanted me
to take my stand up and transcribe it.
I go,
that's gotta be terrible.
Bizarre.
But they were like,
george carlin did it,
but jerry seinfeld did.
I'm like,
no,
they took a check and you know,
maybe they wanted the money.
I don't know,
maybe george had taxes city I pay,
I dunno,
I'm not doing that.
And so they said,
okay,
well we want you to think that you want
to get a laugh like onstage,
like every 30 seconds.
And I was like,
well,
I'm going to write about some stuff that
I don't even think it's funny.
And then no one does that when they're
reading a book labs every 30 seconds.
So I sent them a chapter and they edited
it and changed a bunch of.
Sheila changed the tone of it and I'm
like,
we're done.
I called my manager,
I go tell them we're giving the money
back.
And they were like,
are you fucking serious?
I go,
yeah,
I'll give them their money back.
I don't want to do it.
It's crazy that they would actually
change the language of what,
how you would even write.
I'm never going to do it again.
That way if I do do it again,
if I do write a book,
I'm going to write a book and then I'm
going to sell the book or I'm going to
put the book online.
If nobody wants to buy it,
if nobody wants to buy it and turn it
into a book,
I'm going to go,
okay,
this is the blood your own.
Now you can think it sucks,
but at least it sucks.
And it came from my head and my fingers
like,
I'm going to write it.
I'm going to think it.
You can totally think it sucks and you
don't want it that and look,
there's just the reality of things is
when someone creates something,
it's gonna resonate with a certain
amount of people and other people are
going to hate it.
Just fucking music that I think is
terrible and people love it.
They wait in line,
they go to see these concerts that I
just,
you would have to strap me to a chair
and prime my eyes open like clockwork
orange for me to sit there and watch it
and they can't wait.
It can wait so tastes and and people's
desires very.
But as soon as someone who tries to
enforce their ideas of like what you,
how you should express yourself.
To me,
I thought of it as like very similar to
stand up in the way that like if,
if my standup,
if somebody came along and was like,
like some publicists that I didn't even
know,
not even a friend and wanted to edit my
standup.
You can think my standup socks,
you can not like it,
but if as long as I'm actually paying
attention to it,
as long as I'm actually sitting there
and I'm actually going over it and then
editing it and in thinking about it
myself and practicing and onstage,
I don't want your opinion.
I don't want your input.
You either like it or you don't know
exactly,
but it's me.
Right?
No.
Came out and it sucked.
And then people would be like,
you suck.
You're like,
no,
it actually isn't me.
It's this ghost writer and he sucks.
But I think the movie has to be a
collaboration,
right?
Like if you're doing a movie,
you have actors,
you have writers,
you have directors,
you have producers,
you have the people that are giving you
the money.
That's got to be a goddamn nightmare
because there's a lot of,
lot of different cooks in that kitchen.
But that makes sense to me that you have
to collaborate with these people.
Like if you see,
if you're playing some,
some chicken,
some movie,
and you're,
you know,
you have this idea of how it's supposed
to be.
That's how you audition.
But then you get on set and the
director's like,
abby,
what I want you to do is play a chinese
lady 1500.
You're like,
what?
You know,
you'd be like,
but that's not what I got hired to do.
Like what the fuck is this?
Then you have this chaotic sort of
struggle between the director and the
producers telling you to act one way and
it's a lot of nonsense that one of the
pure things about writing,
whether it's writing stand up or
anything,
it's like it's here's the world and
here's,
here's my vision,
here's the world through my eyes and my
fingers,
and as soon as you allow someone to
start fucking with that,
I just think it's a recipe for disaster.
So my experience wasn't good.
Not that you can't have a good
experience writing a book and maybe
other people have,
but everybody that I've talked to,
the wrote a book tolerable.
Yeah.
That told me it was terrible.
Everybody I know that wrote a book I
have to talk to whitney about.
She didn't have a bad experience.
Get there.
Go use that restroom.
Every.
Abby martin is my favorite hardcore
lefty.
I think she can't figure out where the
doors.
She's my favorite hardcore lefty.
She so rabid.
She said,
I want to get her in a room with sam
harris though,
because she hates sam harris and she
thinks sam harris wants to fucking bomb
every country where brown people live.
She just takes things.
She see how she ramps up.
Like she wants to take things so far,
like you can't even talk to her about
like what social justice warriors do.
She was like,
she's not even thinking about it,
that she's just like,
yeah,
but why?
Why?
They're paying attention to that while
trump is doing this and they're ready to
bomb North Korea and yet,
but it's still an issue.
It's still something.
There's a thing going on.
Yeah.
It's hard to pick.
Pick your thing.
Yeah.
One and be like you said so much info
going on.
Now.
You get distracted from one,
especially if you have a tinge of add.
I do.
Don't you?
Yeah,
will for sure.
Who doesn't?
I don't trust people don't have add.
You know,
like you can concentrate all the time.
I feel like one of those people that can
really sit down and concentrate.
Totally cp that Quick.
That's the scene where you open it up
like a bucket.
How's that even possible?
That doesn't even make sense with me.
What are you saying jamie?
See the lambs being born outside of a
wound.
Did you set story going around today?
That's the apocalypse silence and not
like they weren't.
They weren't a holy god made in there,
but it waS.
It's being tested on.
I think it was sheep,
like a premature births,
so after a instead of a 37 week period,
if it wAs like 28 weeks,
they could put it in the sack and it was
still growing.
Hair eyes opened up.
I'll show you the story real quick.
Do you see that blowjob machine,
this new blowjob robot that they
invented just for blowjobs one better
than the the lip thing that you.
What?
What was it called?
Flashlight.
You have to actually move that thing
around.
Whoa.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
Artificial womb successfully grew baby
sheep and humans could be next.
All my god,
we're.
We're lookIng at this plastic bag where
this baby sheep is inside a positive
lamb is growing in an artificial womb.
For weeks,
oh christ,
what are we doing?
It seems like the next step that
definitely try making one in a bag next
to look in China,
babies and bags and you probably already
have a person that they've made and this
is nUts.
As soon as they started telling you
about this,
it's.
It's already hAppened.
They've already 20 years ago now and
they're just showing us now is probably
ivanka trump was probably born and
raisEd in a bag.
That's how we know chinese.
Chinese still alive.
That's why she's so pretty her.
Right.
They engineered their two sons.
She came out perfect.
They were definitely grown in bags.
Well,
he knows how to cook up a girl.
Yeah,
right.
Like the.
The genes work good on girls.
They weren't good on her,
that's for sure.
Fuck his.
Her husband Is gross.
He's so odd.
the video of him in Iraq or Afghanistan
with the flak jacket on him.
He's a preppy jaslin walking around.
It's like gq,
like endless war.
Fucking
weird.
Yes.
Sick.
Why didn't you give him like some
military glows.
What?
like a complete douche bag.
He looks like he's never worked a
goddamn day in his life.
Prep school,
kid with a vest on soft hAnds.
J dot crew.
Yes.
His hands probably tear on sand.
Just irritated.
Just being like,
when can I come home,
papa?
Look at them.
They're like,
what a complete look kush.
What is that?
They don't even have good word.
People that give you the afghans.
No,
that's.
That is one of the most open secrets and
and going back to why are we in
Afghanistan?
Yeah,
come on.
Yeah.
Well why were we in Vietnam?
But the.
It was one of the most open,
like the information is readily
available.
Totally.
The amount of heroin production that
ramped up since we invaded Afghanistan.
It's insane.
Present and opiod latex as needed for
pharmaceuticals.
It's,
it just goes on and on and on.
It's completely obvious and it's going
to come out soon.
I think that that's really what's
happening there.
Do you think so?
Absolute.
how's it going to come out now?
It's 15 years later.
Good question.
I mean it came out.
Yeah.
when did the sandinista,
like when did all the cocaine
trafficking stuff come out?
We made an all over north freeway.
Rupert.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm like rupert,
totally.
Such a tortured soul to him.
He was such a tortured soul come in at
times that god gave me mushrooms.
Nice.
He came on my podcast,
brought me a giant bag of mushrooms.
Good man.
Great guy.
Good guy.
Loved him.
I didn't agree with.
I didn't agree with them because he was.
He was so crazy about so many different
things about peak oil and stuff like
that whole lung collapsed documentary
that they did where they interviewed him
and he's just sitting there smoking
cigarettes,
talking about the end is near.
I'm like,
jesus dude.
Meanwhile,
all these years later,
everything's fine.
Like he wasn't right about peak oil and
a lot of the other things and he was
always inclined to go towards doom and
gloom,
but I think that that movie,
that documentary collapse and his
worldview,
it was a lot of it was based on how he
thought of things because he was really
depressed and just kind of an
externalization of his own.
He was depression,
anyone up often themselves,
so horrible.
That was one of the saddest suicides of
people that I knew when I knew that he
killed himself because he is.
He sent me some emails.
We talked back and forth and he was.
He was definitely like down in the dumps
and I always felt like god man,
like fuck,
I just needs better people around him
and he just needs more positivity,
but he was so engrossed and entrenched
in corruption and greed and all this
stuff that you saw,
but I'll never forget that fucking
speech
when he stood in front of like.
What was that?
Lapd.
yes.
Well,
he was an art was an lap narcotics
officer and he stood in front of that
cia guy and the.
I forget what the meeting was about and
he was talking about how he had
witnessed cia agents selling narcotics
and the ela and that they had been doing
it forever and that he had been stopped
from prosecuting and arresting them and
everybody went crazy and nuts.
It was nuts.
And then he.
He exposed the whole insider trading
nine slash 11 stuff and peak oil and
yeah,
I mean he was just lambaste it as a
conspiracy theory is toward the end of
his life and it was really sad because
he's done so many amazing things.
That waS a,
that was 1996 town meeting in los
angeles on allegations and this is by
the way folks pre internet and
confronting the cia director and with
the ball the way he did it.
I mean he did it like clearly and loudly
and articulately like it.
Just play it so people who haven't seen
it for my group are important.
Backing up a little bit below.
Yeah.
I will tell you directly as a former los
angeles police,
narcotics detective,
that the agency has dealt drugs
throughout this country for me.
Obviously that is an answer for a lot of
you.
And now can you please.
I refer now.
Can you place I referred to,
right?
Wait,
wait,
wait.
It was so boring.
Why managed care about it?
If you don't like what's going on here,
please leave now.
No,
I haven't seen.
I was trying to control what people are
going crazy.
I mean this was in south central.
Please take your states.
I will get back to you as we rolled back
across to the center section
director,
deutsche.
I will refer you to three specific
agency operations known as um,
a day as pegasus and watchtower resected
by the agency.
I was personally exposed to cia
operations and recruited by cia
personnel who attempted to recruit me
and the late seventies to become
involved in protecting agency drug
operations in this country.
I have been trying to get this out for
18 years and I have the evidence.
my question,
if he was very specific,
sir.
If in the course of the igs
investigations and fred,
his,
his work,
you'll come across evidence of severely
criminal activity.
It's classified well,
you use that classification to hide the
criminal activity or will you tell the
american people the truth?
She's not the best at keeping this group
together,
but that was an intense,
amazing god that opened up a lot of
people's eyes.
Like that was a very,
very important moment.
It was where people realized like,
wait a minute is this guy.
right,
and then it turns out he was.
I mean they really did sell drugs to
fund these black ops and that's how
they.
That's the whole oliver north.
That's the connection between freeway
ricky,
who I also had an apartment.
I mean that's how he made millions and
millions of dollars by selling the cia's
drugs and that's how they funded the
contract versus the sandinistas unreal.
Fucking crazy.
And you're telling me that this opium
just leaving Afghanistan without being
monitored or,
or trafficked whatsoever.
they must have done a way better job of
keeping it together.
They're like,
look,
maybe they learned something,
not have another oliver north type deal.
Yeah,
that shit ain't no good.
I think Afghanistan to this,
the only other country other than if I'm
not mistaken,
Kenya,
that is actually not only the metadata,
you know,
like we're collecting metadata
everywhere,
but that is one of two countries in the
world that wikileaks exposed that we're
actually collecting every phone call.
Every phone call is being archived and
recorded from Afghanistan.
So,
which kind of adds to the weirdness that
somehow these giant heroin,
opium manufacturing operations going on
and we still can't get a grasp on where
it's coming from.
Yet it really affects America.
I mean,
god damn.
What is it like more than car crashes
now?
Our pill overdoses and opiate overdoses.
It's nuts.
It's just surpassed car accidents for
the first time ever and insane.
I had dennis mckenna on recently was
explaining to me,
yeah,
it was pretty awesome.
He's such a genIus man.
He's so spooky.
Smart.
But he was explaining to me carfentanil,
which is a new form of fentanyl that's
even more powerful than fentanyl still
scheduled to though.
Marijuana schedule one never killed a
fucking human being ever that he was
saying that the head of a pin contains
enough for you to die of an overdose.
Yeah.
What?
Why?
Why would he do that?
Why don't we make that easy?
Because like hippos,
we need a handout.
They hurt.
They have joint aches.
His poor hippos.
We have to figure out.
We have to figure out how to to
authoritarians brace for more overdoses
after Maryland desa linked to elephants.
Additive,
yeah,
horse tranquilizers now run elephant
sedatives.
I thought we were on ketamine and now
we're on.
Now we're on a.
It's so potent to overdoses 10,000
times more potent and time.
5,000
times more potent than a thousand times.
Not like 110.
That is so insane.
This is why philip seymour hoffman and
so many other people die of overdoses
because the drug war and these people
just sell like laced heroin and shit.
And It's so dangerous and yeah,
it's,
it's absolutely horrible.
When we were talking about bourdain's
show,
he had a great show on Massachusetts on
cnn show and it was about the heroin
epidemic that's hit Massachusetts and
many other places as well.
But he kind of talked about
Massachusetts because,
um,
they,
they had a few people that they were
referring to where these people,
they got hooked on oxycontin and
oxycodone.
I don't know what the difference is to,
you know,
um,
and then they made it much more
difficult to get.
And then as soon as these people made it
much more difficult to get.
You're dealing with these people that
have addictions and so then they started
doing actual heroin,
so they're taking hillbilly heroin and
then they get addicted to that.
You know,
if you have a back pain or you hurt
yourself,
they'll fucking write you a script for
that shit.
easy.
And I have a bunch of friends that got
hooked.
I,
I have a family member that just became
a loser,
was a hardworking guy,
had his shit together,
got hooked on those pills.
Loser.
Now no one talks to them.
He's just gone his own fucking kids.
Don't talk to them.
Gone.
And um,
my buddy brendan,
he broke his nose.
They had them on that shit.
And then three months later he's taking
it every day,
still his friends had come over his
house and scoop it up out of his,
um,
out of is a medicine cabinet.
Addictive,
scary stuff.
Scary.
And then you just need it.
You just need it.
I'll get,
I'll get off it eventually,
but right now I need it.
Oh,
I had my wisdom teeth taken out when I
was 17 and I feel like I got addicted to
them that the doctor gave me.
Yeah,
I loved it.
How could you not?
I never did it.
What's?
Yeah,
I never did it.
I've got a knee surgery once and they
gave me something.
It was either percocets or viking and I
cannot remember,
but it made me so stupid.
I remember thinking I would rather be
pain.
I'm pretty good with pain,
but I'm not good with anything that
makes me feel stupid beCause I feel
vulnerable.
Like I'd rather I'd rather be hurting
and aware than I w I don't know,
like a numb guy.
I don't like numbing out.
That's one of the reasons why I like pot
because it makes me hyper aware and
hyper vigilant and really sensitive and,
and it makes me,
you know,
people,
you can call it paranoid.
Some people call it paranoid,
but I,
I'm,
I think it's more like hyperawareness,
you know,
in that hyper awareness you have to take
into account all the variables that you
are going to die,
that you are in a,
a ball that spinning a thousand miles an
hour with a thin layer of gas,
flat,
flat earth.
No spinning,
spinning around.
Oh wait,
just stationery.
Yeah,
everything's doing something around us.
It's not.
Whenever I hear the flutter thing,
I'm just like,
don't ask her not to take photos from
space now or you can see the earth
behind you live.
There's a live you can watch from the
space station.
Anybody can soros.
It's no cgr.
It's a hologram buddy that I talked to
you that believes in flutter at the
show,
that japanese satellite that takes a
photo,
high resolution every 10 minutes from
22,000
miles away,
a full picture of the earth.
They think it's fake.
That's all you have to say.
It's fake.
By the way.
They keep saying that you can't fly over
antarctica.
Listen to me.
You fucks.
You can fly over antarctica.
Can't fly government.
Stop you from flying away article.
They don't regularly scheduled flights.
They fly over antarctica.
Not only that,
there's a quantas pilot who filmed it
because he was tired of that bullshit.
Mic west.
The guy who runs the man who runs metta,
bunk metabolic is a website designed for
debunking conspiracy theories with facts
and science.
He's,
they have many,
many pages on the flat earth on that
website of debunking all the arguments
against flatter it.
So he's going to come on the website and
we're going to go over them.
One,
I'm going to die one.
Some reason it's still growing.
It's because me and my $3 a month that I
take from george soros,
my,
um,
my round earth.
How much you think they get paid you.
If the earth was flat and you knew that
the earth was flat,
could they even pay you enough to not
tell people?
No.
There's no way.
There'd be no way.
Think of how many people you'd have to
tell or how many people you'd have to
keep fire up the moon landing thing.
Man,
that's a cover up.
The flutter thing.
The moon landing at least happened in
1969 and it happened with a limited
amount of people that were had access to
all the technology.
There was no internet.
They controlled the media and we never
went back.
So there's all sorts of beautiful things
connect together to form a nice juicy
fat conspiracy that I love.
I love the moon landings.
I secretly not so secretly covered that
one.
Like no other conspiracy.
I would love it if it was true.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a great quote from bill clinton
from his book,
my life on the moon landing and it is,
um,
it's fascinating because he's talking
about an old carpenter and he says the
carpenter says that,
uh,
them mtv fellers that he didn't believe
the moon landing and that those tv flow
fellows,
I never believe anything because they
can pretty much do anything and make you
believe that it's real and you don't.
He goes,
back then I thought he was a crank,
but after eight years of the white
house,
I was wondering if he's not ahead of his
time.
That's in bill clinton's book series.
You want to hear something really quick
and people are going to go on with the
moon.
Moon.
Are you good,
bro?
I thought you gave up on that.
I will give you the most cryptic piece
of information about the moon landing.
Neil armstrong gave a speech on the 25th
anniversary of the moon landings and it
is one of the most what the fuck
speeches you'll ever hear in your life
because it's not a guy saying,
look,
we went to the moon and it was an
amazing.
You kids are going to accomplish amazing
things as well.
Pull up neil armstrong's cryptics says
she doesn't remember if there were
stars,
no known,
but that is one of the things that they
did say it wasn't neil armstrong by the
way,
it was Michael Collins had said that
Michael Collins said that he didn't
recall seeing any stars,
but then later in his book he recalled
in great depth what the stars looked
like and how amazing they were and how
incredible they were him later.
But meanwhile he was in the lunar lander
is whole time.
So play this,
play this
on the 25th anniversary of the event in
1994,
neil armstrong meter rare public
appearance and held back tears as he
spoke.
These brief triptych remarks before the
next generation of taxpayers as they
tour the white house.
Listen to this
today.
We have with this group of students some
on america's best to you.
We say we have only completed a
beginning.
We leave you much.
That is under.
There are great ideas.
Undiscovered breakthroughs are available
to those who can remove one of truths,
protective layers.
Is this a funny thing that happened on
the way that the moon did?
That movie is nuts.
When they showed the apollo mission and
it shows them like putting the piece of
paper where it makes it look like
they're farther away.
I was like,
what are they doing?
Yeah,
have no idea.
They're filming through a window there,
filming the earth through a circular
window and they have the cabin of the
lunar module blacked out.
They have all these things over the
windows like a set and they using
diffused lighting to operate the
controls.
It's crazy.
It's so strange because it's the one
conspiracy that still to this day you go
home because there's no technological
achievement from 1969 site easier,
cheaper,
and faster to reproduce today other than
the moon landing is they went six times
seven attempts,
six to successful attempts.
Apollo 13,
obviously they never went.
They did that accident that made tom
hanks great movie,
but that was the only time human beings
have been more than 400 miles from the
earth's surface.
Every other gun back.
Not only,
we haven't gone back,
we never even left the magnetosphere.
It's crazy.
We've never gone through the van allen
radiation belts since then.
We never went into deep space like all
the way out and back like around the
Moon.
They never even did like a fly by since
then.
That's insane how much it costs a
shitload of money,
but so does the space shuttle.
So does the space station,
so does a lot of things.
He does cost a lot of money and that is
a good argument,
but it is weird that we still had a
space program from it.
This,
it's like,
look,
I'm not saying that we didn't go,
but what I am saying is that,
that is why that conspiracy.
Totally.
No,
It's super crazy and that movie you can
kind of go through and debunk the
lighting stuff,
the stars,
the van allen radiation belt thing,
but then when it gets to that end
senior,
like,
what the hell is going on there?
It's nuts.
It reAlly is creepy with that guy.
He's very compelling.
He was,
he was all in that guy.
The guy who made that movie funny thing
happened on the way to the moon.
This was when I was deep in the whole
moon landing thing.
Um,
but there was a first one that got me is
when I was on news radio in the
nineties.
They had a documentary on fox called
conspiracy theory.
Did we ever go to the moon?
And that one is really compelling and
one of the reasons why it's compelling
us because there's more than one
occasion where they used the exact same
backdrop.
They have the same backdrop,
but they were supposed to be on a
totally different part of the moon and
they had the exact same background where
it looks fake as fuck.
You want to see something really fake
looking google astronauts on
trampolines.
You want to see some ridiculous shit.
There's one one video clip did they did.
Now here's what someone explained to me
that it's entirely likely,
and this made a lot of sense,
that it's entirely likely.
This is during the nixon administration,
by the way.
It was all going on.
Massive deception.
I mean nixon was just a fucking fraud in
every way,
shape or form and a crook and a liar.
that it's entirely possible that they
filmed a lot of stuff and that they
filmed all this fake stuff and they
passed it off as the real footage,
but that they actually did go,
but they couldn't get footage of it.
And one of the reasons why they probably
couldn't get footage of it,
if that's the case,
is that you can't even get that fucking
film through the radar detector at the
airport or the,
the,
um,
the x ray machine at the airport without
killing it.
Right.
I was looking at some stuff up on this
the other day,
the van van van allen radiation belts,
the spaceship itself and all the stuff
they were wearing would've protected
them from most of the radiation that
would have potentially harmed them or
anything that allegedly.
And it's,
it's uh,
they also didn't go through what they
went through,
like the donut hole that's at the top.
Like the way the van allen radiation
belts apparently surrounded the earth.
It surrounds it like a doughnut.
So there's an area where you can go
through.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well there's an area where you can go
through with.
They're only exposed to the radiation
for like an hour or something like that.
How,
I mean with all this deception back in
started from the beginning,
look at this.
So this is.
This is when I was balls deep,
but look at this footage like what is
going on here?
Like what is this guy doing?
So here's the thing,
the physics back then they're.
They're not the same on every mission,
like the way they move around.
It's not the same amount of palo 11 as
it is on apollo 16 or whatever the last
mission was that it looks different when
they're moving around,
but this one is the weirdest one because
here these guys are,
they're in one six earth's gravity and
there's fucking juMping around through
the air and you can't see their feet
like you only see their feet when
they're in the air.
They just,
they were hiding behind this lunar
module and they're bouncing around in a
way that you never saw
them bounce around before.
That's not in any other moon mission.
So I think it's entirely Possible that
they fake some stuff and that there
could have been an issue with them being
on the surface of the moon.
Yeah,
and also being on the surface of the
moon,
the radiation on the surface of the
there was no protection to those cameras
and there's no.
There's no magnetos fear.
There's nothing.
Those hassled bad cameras that they had
that they kept in the center of their
chests.
Those weird looking cameras that they
used.
There was nothing different about those.
There was nothing protecting,
protecting us when I was reading.
Yeah,
but not the camera.
The camera was external.
It was in the suit.
This external.
It was like this.
It was out in front of them.
Well,
I don't know man.
I just read that the pentagon spent like
half a billion dollars on just fake isis
videos and propaganda videos for
terrorist recruitment.
What do you know why they did that
though?
That's.
That's something that people bring up a
lot,
but it's a little misleading.
what they did was they made these videos
for real player and so when someone
would watch these videos,
they would collect metadata,
so location the person was watching and
that way they could find out who is
watching these terrorists recruitment
videos and they get it.
You're right,
you're right,
but so is everything the government does
and like if they want to try to figure
out where isis was,
they have unlimited money.
I mean they can kind of do whatever the
fuck they want.
someone said,
hey,
I've got an idea.
We'll make these videos while these
terrorist recruitment videos and
everything like that.
The garland,
Texas,
um,
that first isis attack and the us was
really an fba.
Once again it was an fbi informant to
fbi informants were on the scene.
Why didn't they stop the attack ballou
it guys.
Right,
right.
Well,
here's a better one,
but they do all the time.
How about that video that we were
supposed to be led to believe was the
reason why they attack bengazi?
Remember that you remember?
Oh yeah.
I remember that fake video that was
like,
that was about the movie and everybody
was saying everybody was saying that
that movie was the reason why they
attacked us,
which was a lie.
They knew it was a lot.
They had a cia operation running weapons
out of this hub,
but they're like,
oh,
it's about a movie.
Everyone hates this movie.
Youtube.
You're watched the movie now.
It's fucking unbelievably bad.
Oh god.
I'm so bad that you don't even believe
it's real movement.
Seems like create that movie too.
I would guess so.
I don't know,
but I would say probably.
I would say,
yeah,
I would guess thing that bothers me
about the isis stuff is that,
like I said before,
that 70,000
number.
It's like you could just say anything's
isis.
Isis gigs that we dropped them moab on
and it's just like,
oh,
it's the nicest cave and that's why 70
percent of americans support bombing the
shit out of Afghanistan because isis was
there.
What happened?
I felt like there was more critical
thinking that people were upset that we
were playing judge,
jury and executioner.
I think now we just kill isis and mass
and it's just no one questioned that at
all.
I think it's like what we were talking
about earlier.
There's just too much information.
There's too much going on and the they
bombed.
They drop the mother of all bombs right
after we had accidentally killed a bunch
of people
that were on our side in Syria.
Right?
Yep.
So like,
that was like a good time,
like we had accidentally fucked up and
killed some syrian rebels and like,
ooh,
didn't he kill it?
Yeah.
We killed a bunch of people that we were
training in arming alqaeda and sees
trump.
And you know,
what trump learned after the Syria
strike,
he learned that he can get because all
he cares about,
he's like a little child wants positive
reinforcement and he hates,
you know,
the fake news.
Cnn,
why don't you,
why don't you cover me fairly.
He goeS out there and does these press
conferences begging the news to cover
him better because that's all he cares
about.
But that's what he learned is that he
can get bipartisan support and praise
from the media if you just bombed the
shit out of people.
So that's what he learns.
So then he dropped the moab and what's
next?
Trump.
Because you know now how to be popular,
just like reagan came in and was,
was seen as a joke until he got swept
into the military industrial complex and
became a war president and I think that
trump came in as a reality star
president joke and he's surrounded
himself with more generals than any
other president since world war ii and
he's just letting them lead him wherever
they want and,
and of course general just want to be in
charge of of conflicts so they can get
more stars and emblems and honors and
lead us into different things.
That's theIr career to bring this up
earlier.
But I forgot
that was one of the things that was most
creepy is that he's saying he's going to
let the military do their job.
Like,
like oversight of the military is what
eisenhower warned us about at the end of
his term.
I mean,
remember when eisenhower was leaving,
he talked about the military industrial
complex and everybody's like,
what the fuck?
But that was something that was
broadcast on television and back in the
day,
that's when it ended.
It was broadcast on tv.
Some people listened and then business
went about as usual and it wasn't like
today where you could watch that video
over and over again.
When you see that video,
eisenhower saying military,
we are industrial complex.
Yeah.
Trump is now adding 10 percent of the
fucking budget,
cutting all of these agencies and
bolstering the pentagon even more.
We already have the biggest military in
the goddamn world.
Bigger than the next 10 countries
combined.
Why is this happening?
This is whAt makes America great.
Just reverting back to like a completely
disgusting.
It's sick,
man.
What do we do,
abby martin,
what do we do?
Well,
okay,
if president abby gets selected,
what do we do?
Well,
first,
uh,
abolish money in politics and start some
sort of true democratic representation
where you have simple laws to prosecute
criminals.
Whether or not they have money or
they're billionaires.
So if you're a corporate criminal,
you got to fucking jail.
If you pull it sounds like suicide by
government.
it's sick,
man.
I mean,
I,
yeah,
it's,
it's hard to say,
but I just know that trump has taken us
down a very dangerous path and these
people who are thinking that he's
somehow anti empire,
andy deep state are very confuse.
Bannon iS a psycho.
Bannon wants war,
he wants war with China,
but it's naomi outs know the,
I think that's just on paper because
trump didn't like people calling him
president bannon and so he's still
attending the national security council.
He still has a say.
We know that he really is him and these
billionaires,
Robert Mercer in the koch brothers who
have somehow aren't globalists,
right?
But they really are backing bannon and
trump and they,
uh,
they hedge their bets band and tried to
do it before with pailin,
but it didn't work.
he saw sarah pailin is like the trump
one point zero and made this giant movie
about her and try to latch onto her and
then she flopped.
She saw,
sure what with pailin with ted nugent,
ted nugent's wife and kid rock and kid
friendly.
So creepy.
Trump in the oval.
This is idiocracy idiocracy.
It's like a fucking bass pro shop video,
a photo from a cabela's catalog.
I mean,
it's hilarious when you look at the five
of them next to trump and when you were
saying the military do your job,
he's already like changed the rules of
engagement where we look for kIlling a
thousand civilians to be killed.
A thousand civilians in martin.
Look at this.
Yeah.
Yup.
Carpet bombed and area and mozal a
couple of weeks ago killed 230 people.
Didn't hear a peep about it from the
mainstream media.
Let's just move onto the next one.
The photo then.
Look,
this is what's happening,
but seriously,
kid rock's girlfriends hot.
She's hot as fuck.
Kudos kid.
You're hotter than I than him.
That's great.
Sure.
Of course.
Where does this fear of pailin?
Husband?
No.
Is that good?
I don't even know what the hell he looks
like.
You don't know what it looks like.
No,
I don't want quarterly out of my
periphery like I don't got a good
hunting show.
Sarah,
sarah dinner kid.
Just have another baby.
That was her fault.
Abby.
Maybe one day you'll have promiscuous
daughters and you'll understand,
won't be promoted.
What's it called?
Like how she's just a whole like,
uh,
she,
she praises don't have sex
obstinance thing or who you're talking
about.
There was promoting.
Pray the gay away.
Was that pence?
Yes.
Pray the gay away.
That's a,
that's a good sign that someone's trying
to fuck dudes.
Oh,
for sure.
Right?
For sure.
I'm michele bachmann and her husband,
everyone's forgot about her.
I remember her husband who is maybe the
gay guy that's ever walked the face of
the planet.
So gay guy comes glitter.
Oh,
gay.
Like glitter and shoots out of his dick
number.
Last time I was,
and
you showed me that dennis prager video,
which was that it was an argument about
Israel where he was talking about why
Israel deserves to exist and stuff after
being there.
Man.
Holy shit.
I feel like people have no idea what.
I didn't even know what the hell is
going on until I went to palestine and
saw how crazy it was.
But what is it like?
Tell me,
give me your thoughts and your
mistakenly thinks that hamas like
controls palestine.
That's not true at all.
There's,
there's three different areas that were
drawn up with the original partition.
It's the west bank,
which is totally under military rule by
Israel,
and then there's the gaza strip,
which is like the open air prison,
which they bombed the shit out of like
every couple of years and hamas controls
that area.
And then there's jerusalem,
which is an international city center,
um,
that both arabs and jews live in.
But the westbank has been occupied
militarily since 1967.
And it's complete martial law.
There's checkpoints.
All political parties are illegal.
You can't.
having a gun is like the least of it.
You can't hold a flag.
You can't belong to a political party.
You literally can't do shit if you're a
palestinian.
You just have to sit there and submit
'em.
And if even if you share a photo of
someone who was killed by an israeli
soldier,
you go to jail and you go to jail for
the amount of,
like months that.
Yeah,
based on the shares and likes of the
photo,
they'll,
they'll penalize you more and put you in
prison for longer and longer.
I mean,
I'll just tell you one story.
Put a photo on social media like you put
someone who died and there'll be like,
you're sharing a martyr and inciting
people to like commit suicide.
Like on behalf of palestinians.
You go to jail and they put them in
jail.
There's a 99 point seven percent
conviction rate.
Kids are tortured,
kids are in prison.
It is absolutely insane.
We went to the first day that we were
there,
we went to a funeral of some guy,
some farmer who was shot by israeli
forces and we went to the funeral is
horrible,
you know,
all the women are wailing and crying and
as relieving the israeli forces had set
up a checkpoint right outside of this
dude's house and started tear gassing
and shooting rubber bullets.
I get people who were simply attending
the funeral just to punish people for
attending the funeral.
Um,
we went to another girl's house named
[inaudible] who's a,
who got shot in the vagina for
peacefully protesting at some protests
and they shot,
they shot,
they shot 200 people that day.
One guy next to her diet,
another guy who was paralyzed,
they have a policy called shoot to
cripple where they shoot guys in the
dicks is fucking nuts,
man.
The west bank is no joke.
I thought that I was going to die
several times.
We were at this checkpoint going through
calandria and there was this old man
walking like clearly drunk or something
and kind of walking a little bit toward
the checkbook.
They started shooting at him.
Bolts are ricocheting off the thing.
And I,
you know,
my partner mike who was an invading
soldier of Iraq was just like,
we're gonna die like they're shooting
this guy,
there's bullets ricocheted.
I.
It was absolutely insane.
And as we go through the checkpoint,
the soldiers like,
hey,
stay safe out there.
And I was like,
yeah,
when you guys are arbitrarily shooting
people.
And,
and the person who was driving us had
just told us that a couple months prior
to that,
some woman,
palestinian woman,
because you can't go to jerusalem,
like if you're a palestinian,
there's barely any palestinians were
even allowed to go pray at the most holy
site,
the dome of the rock and jerusalem,
you can't go to the beach,
you're just completely constricted in a
prison and you can't travel.
And,
and he was just telling us that months
before we went through this checkpoint,
someone was going through the checkpoint
because they got a permit to go into
jerusalem,
which is like a lifetime golden ticket,
like willy wonka and they're walking and
they get and she just got executed.
And then yeah,
she just got executed and she was
bleeding out at this checkpoint.
And her little brother tried to help her
and they shot him too.
And they're like hiding the video of
this.
And this is just a day because they
fucking hate palestinians and
palestinians are our animals to these
people.
It's sick,
man.
It's sick.
It's really,
really sick.
Joe and I,
I couldn't even get into.
We were banned from going into this
territory because I was told by the
israeli government that I was a
propagandist and that I was like an
enemy agent and so I wasn't allowed to
go into gaza,
so gaza's hell,
but the west bank is an under martial
law and everything's illegal and you
can't do a goddamn thing and it's super
cool.
Like we went to this place called ramola
that was just like,
um,
oakland and where they're smoking weed,
there's like openly gay people.
They're like,
it's just completely different than what
people think of palestine.
You know,
people think of it as just a bunch of
people with turbans on blown and hamas
is like,
yo,
you elected hamas and hamas doesn't want
Israel to exist.
It's like,
well actually hamas is controlling this
one area for a reason because it was
built as this surplus.
When Israel was created,
millions of refugees were put miles away
from the homes that they were ethnically
cleansed from and put into refugee camps
in gaza.
And when the israeli military wanted
more and more land,
by the way,
all settlements in Israel are illegal.
All of them are illegal in the west
bank,
but they just keep creating more and
more and more and we would go to these
villages,
have just arab people living in these
villages and the settlers will come.
You have to be a fanatical fucking
asshole to move from California to an
arab village in palestine and setup a
goddamn tractor trailer and just live on
top of their home and they can have a
giant machine guns.
They can fire bomb you.
They can shoot you,
they can beat you up.
They're protected by the state.
You can go with a tractor trailer,
set up a home.
The state immediately runs a waterline
of power line and a military outpost to
protect you and the arabs are just
sitting there waiting to get killed or
attacked.
It's absolutely insane and the way home
demolitions worker in st louis because
they either deliver a piece of paper
with a rock over it and they're like,
here,
if you find it good for you and if you
don't,
then you're screwed.
And that's if you're lucky.
If you're not lucky,
you'll just.
Your home will be invaded by settlers.
And you'll be forced out of your home.
There's videos of this all over the
internet of like groups of settlers
going and literally taking over arabs
homes and then they just are forced out.
It's crazy,
man.
It's,
it's completely way crazier than I ever
could have imagined.
How long were you over there?
For?
A month.
Yeah.
And we were,
you know,
we were simply and people want to
quabble about like,
oh,
it's not apartheid.
There are different fucking license
plates for arabs and jews,
like you cannot go to areas like israeli
soldiers were arbitrarily set up
checkpoints in just shut you out of your
neighborhood and force you to walk three
miles to your home.
Like they can do whatever they want
because you are under martial law and
you can't,
you have no mobility,
like you have no freedom.
so it's really,
it's really bad.
And we just did a whole series on the
empire files talking about how Israel
was created up until today.
And we go over like the settlements,
the demolitions,
the jail,
and why I think there's no hope from
within israeli society to change because
it's becoming a more theocratic state
and a more fascist state as it grows
because you have to be.
To maintain this jewish supremacist
state,
you have to be like more fascist and
more controlling and more militaristic
and the way that you rule society just
like the us.
I mean people who are conSidered
outlier,
fringe assholes 30 years ago are now
like the christian evangelicals are now
in power.
It's really,
really crazy.
I mean it's not the same because Israel
is a white nationalist,
ethno supremacist state and you see the
way that they treat ethiopians and
african refugees and,
and it becomes obvious that even if
you're a jew and you're black,
you still are a second class citizen
there.
Have you interviewed anybody that's pro
Israel to interview a lot of israelis?
And what did you.
I interviewed a lot of israelis.
It seems like a lot of israelis.
Well,
think about this in order to really
reject the notion like you,
it's like rejecting being an american
and it's such a hard thing for people to
really accept.
So there's a huge mobilization within
Israel.
People who are opposed to the military
who talk openly about how awful the
occupation is,
how brutal it is,
how they,
you know,
all the crimes they committed,
but you'll very rarely find anti
zionists who will come out and say that
the notion of a jewish state is wrong
because then it means you're just
rejecting everything that you are and
like,
who are you then if you're an israeli
and you are not zionist,
you know,
it's like,
it's just a really hard notion for you
to wrap your mind around.
But we interviewed about 40 israelis,
man on the streets and,
and to be leftist as a slur.
So like a lot of israelis don't even
entertain the notion of,
oh,
maybe there shouldn't be an occupation
at all.
They're all just like,
okay,
well maybe we should have a more humane
occupation.
Maybe we should give them water.
Like maybe they should have their own
water.
Saying the occupation,
occupation of palestine.
So the west bank of the west bank has
been militarily occupied for since 67.
So when Israel was created in 48,
there were those three partitioned to
areas that I talked about and ever since
that happened,
Israel has just continued to take over
more and more land in the west bank.
so these settlements just keep growing
and growing and growing and growing.
Um,
and so,
you know,
over time there was mass resistances
that happen and then in 67 Israel was
like,
we're just gonna do a large scale
invasion and try to take over all the
land and then they just stayed and
occupied this area and they just had
been there ever since.
And so that's like the huge
international crime when the
international community is like,
by the way these settlements are illegal
and we're like condemning you at the un
and the us just vetoes it every time
because the us is just like boys with
Israel unconditionally.
It's sick man.
And then they just sign that
$10,000,000,000
aid package given it to Israel for the
next 10 years is I actually,
I think it was $30,000,000,000
over the next 10 years,
which is crazy because this would never
be able to happen if it weren't just
completely supported by the us.
And why is this us?
I don't know.
Um,
I think that the us loves using Israel
as a military garrison.
They love usIng that strategic point in
the middle east to have.
Um,
and also someone was shedding some
light.
This israeli soldier that I interviewed
who was amazing,
his name is ronna ferrante and he was
telling me that the military aid package
that we just signed with Israel,
it may look like just a gift.
Israel were like,
here's $30,000,000,000.
But he said,
really what it was doing,
Israel has been its own arms dealer it,
it actually is one of the number number
one weapons dealers in the world now.
It actually did like this huge deal with
India.
And so the us felt threatened,
right?
Because we're the military might.
And so we kind of locked in Israel with
this giant packet and we're like,
you have to buy us armaments through
this,
so if you accept this $30,000,000,000
a deal,
you have to go through our military like
weapons to buy if you want this money.
So that's what this guy was saying.
He said it's actually a gift to us that
we're locking down like our control over
this country.
But honestly it's becoming so unpopular.
Obama had a big feud with netanyahu.
I mean,
trump is disgusting because jared
kushner is personally invested in
illegal settlements.
And he like his boys with netanyahu
financial.
Yeah.
The cushner foundation.
Like his family,
his actual foundation has funded illegal
settlements.
But if you fund some charity in gaza,
you will go to jail for supporting
terrorism.
But you can go fund the legal
settlements and sponsor settlers to go
and live on top of arab villages.
And that's fine.
I guess that's freedom.
Do you think that most people just
aren't aware?
Yes.
I didN't even know.
I had no idea how crazy it wasn't for a
while.
and I a pc.
You were criticized about on your show,
were you,
you were furious about,
oh my god.
Yeah,
and people are just,
it's so confusing and convoluted on
purpose because that it really relies on
Israel being the victim and for people
not really understanding that
palestinians are not all terrorists and
that it's really just a case of being
occupied and like getting freedom.
So it's,
it's really tough man.
But a lot of these israelis want,
they just want to push the palestinians.
They wanted,
they want them to go,
they want them.
They don't care as long as they're gone,
as long as they're gone.
I mean,
here's an example of how crazy it is.
El rosario as a soldier there,
you know,
and in the us,
when police kill black people and we
have rallies like black lives matter,
people have rallies in support of these
people who get killed in Israel.
They have mass rallies,
10,000,
20,000
people strong in tel aviv.
If a soldier executes and unarmed
palestinian man and gets a slap on the
wrist.
Like this guy leo rosaria executed an
unarmed palestinian.
It was on video.
It's a horrific video and because there
was this international uproar about it,
Israel had to put him on house arrest.
The israeli government put him on house
arrest and that was enough for like mass
mobilization of tens of thousands of
people to come out and protest the fact
that he was getting even reprimanded as
slap on the wrist.
They get house arrest,
video available.
Absolutely,
and they're chanting death to arabs.
There's tens of thousands of google and
look up dan cohen and david schien.
They do aMazing journalism there.
They were living that.
David jean is israeli.
He's.
He's been there and he documents these
crazy rallies,
fascist fucking rallies that no one else
has shown and until I saw that until I
saw People chanting death to the
videographers because they hate when you
even film like what's going on there?
Death to the leftists.
A really scary man.
It's just a completely different
society.
Here it is.
Nuts.
It's a long videos.
It was just the two of them.
That bro skis.
Yeah,
go forward until you see this.
Just like crazy.
We're being criticized all over the
world is if they are righteous,
killed for less than the United States
is the worst.
They bomb pop,
so she's basically saying,
how dare you criticize us when you guys
do this shit,
which is a good point.
Just the war policemen,
usu blacks,
and it's okay because the whole circus,
the world per se,
that israeli army are really murderers.
We gave them an official license to call
us murderers instead of covering it up
and dealing with it ourselves.
Why make so much noise?
Whoa.
Instead she's pro covering it up.
Once a soldier understands that he can
be charged with manslaughter next time
he'll think twice,
and that hesitation is likely to cost
soldiers part of this.
Wow,
this is interesting.
Our brother lr,
so everyone's cheering on the soldier
were certainly now sitting in an open
jail,
an army base in the center of the
country watching tv.
The kid will pay,
but then at vizio,
he's in at all
look alone,
a law.
The jewish people support you.
The jewish people are with you and he's
about to say,
jewish people did not abandon their
soldiers started to chant death.
They're present or the future.
Whoa.
you are not alone.
They're mad because they're all tight.
Summary execution is like an
institutionalized thing,
so they're all like,
why the hell is this guy getting
persecuted for something that everyone
just acknowledges that this is
so the soldiers have to be in their
eyes,
so just have to be able to just execute
anytime they want.
Go to that,
go to that huge rally at the end.
Do you think that they feel like trapped
and surrounded and that they make this
justification because they feel like
there's arab states all around?
Oh my god,
they have a fucking concert,
so yeah.
No,
that was wearing adidas.
Don't.
The help of god was really shoulders
would return home peaceably.
No hope of god.
All Terrorists will be neutralized.
Go to that part.
Yeah.
Go to their flowers in the gunbarrel
israeli national.
Yeah.
Where it shows the
thank you for coming good and told her
respect part in this video.
people should watch it where it says,
yeah,
we'll flip the country over free.
The boy debt.
The arabs Were,
does it?
That's the hard part.
Come in.
so how did these guys get away with
film?
And this is the king of Israel.
The dog.
yeah,
it's really great.
It's very intense.
I mean,
yeah,
of course israelis are indoctrinated.
I dunno,
it's a 10 minute video,
but it's part of the,
when the giant rallies,
we have it in our videos too on the um,
on empire files.
Yeah,
it's really wild.
We didn't want to vote ultra right
square,
full the squares for.
Because he's saying that the
establishment makes it seem like an arab
as a son of a whore,
a jew as a soul.
Wow.
His friends asked you here,
embarrassed.
They don't want this on film.
We only came to embrace and love the
army and the soldiers.
He's trying to change the football club.
Yes.
Anybody?
No,
no.
This isn't about killing.
ARabs were about celebrating the army.
Anyway,
there's some really crazy stuff like my
friend david,
was it listening to terrible music.
Oh god.
Fucking sick of waiting for peace.
I will know her on their dream about it
until I die together with this holy
crowd.
I utter a prayer.
Jesus christ,
like we would go in there
huge jerusalem and tel aviv and people
be like,
are you arab?
And I'm like,
what?
Like they just immeDiately just have
this distrust and hatred for arabs.
It's extremely intense and like you were
saying,
I mean this is the thing that starts
from childhood.
You are indoctrinated to think that
every single person is trying to kill
you.
So all these people or these kinds of
film this,
they're kind of fucked now they,
they've been jumped.
My friend david shane was junk because
someone came up to when he was like,
where's your fucking flag?
Because you like were israeli flags as
capes.
A lot of these people like wear them.
It's extremely fascist and he was just
like my flag.
And they're like,
yeah,
where's your fucking flag?
And they'd beat him up,
took his camera.
And this happens all the time.
I mean they,
they luckily he's an israeli jew so he
doesn't get that much heat.
But my friend dan is also,
you know,
it looks like a,
he is a jew,
so they don't really give him heat,
but like yeah,
it's really dangerous to film there and
it's really dangerous to document what's
going on.
They must be particularly furious about
israeli jews that expose this stuff.
Oh yeah.
There are definitely targeted.
Yeah.
It's dangerous for them to be in the
country for sure.
That,
that really ruthless patriotism.
Right?
The woman was saying that the soldiers
might hesitate if they can be charged
with manslaughter,
you know,
to move.
Yeah.
It's pretty intense.
So I feel like,
yeah,
the whole Israel
thing and people are confused about like
bannon and this antisemitism thing.
Look,
you can,
you can hate jews and love Israel.
Just like Richard Spencer is a perfect
example.
Richard spencer sees Israel as the
perfect example of what he wants the us
to be because it's an ethnos supremacist
nationalist state and that's what these
people love.
So you can be anti semitic and still
love the notion of fostering like a
certain group,
a certain identity.
so does,
does he think we should have mel
mandatory military service or they do
it?
Well,
he,
he definitely doesn't want different
races breeding so I think that he
probably just wants like an insular
society.
Yeah,
I'll just like white people.
She is christ nazi-ism when when you get
a bunch of people and everybody has to
join the army.
He,
he,
there's a disturbing.
There's a bond that they have.
It's very different than the regular
civilian bond and the like the
indoctrination that you get once you've
been in the military and you fought side
by side with your brothers and sisters
in arms.
So until a totally different feeling,
you know,
I know,
I know a lot of people that have been in
the military and some of them got deeper
in it than others and like those people,
like it's almost like an us versus them.
Their society that know that whole chris
kyle sheep dog thing.
right.
You know,
like there's there protecting us,
but they together as a group are much
tighter than any other group in the
United States.
I mean there's,
there's division in all groups.
Right.
But I got to imagine that the bond that
they have as israelis,
all of them have been,
been in the military,
all of them living in this one small
area surrounded by arab states.
It's got to be super intense.
They should've created Israel,
not in the god damn middle of the middle
east.
Put it in fucking Australia.
Like what the hell were they thinking
isn't about the history of that region.
But was it mean sikes,
pico,
western empires.
You basically just drew a line through
the middle east and divided all these
countries and formed all these borders
back like 120 years ago.
I don't know,
like 19.
When was sex pico?
I don't know.
Somewhere around that time.
So anyway,
fast forward to when the ottoman empire
was colonizing this area and the british
were occupying what is palestine,
right?
And the zionist lobby was really strong.
This is well before the holocaust.
And they were super,
super strong and embolden and they were
negotiating with the,
um,
with the brits about where they can form
like a jewish state.
And there really was no support until
the holocaust where they were able to
sell,
like,
you know,
the fear more and there was even false
flag attacks were zionist organizations
were going around different arab
countries and committing terrorism and
insane,
like,
all right,
like the jews need to come and escape
that you guys are being persecuted.
Like they would actually carry out
terrorism,
it like and stuff.
And thiS is all documented.
Yeah.
But the ethnic cleansing that went on,
I mean,
it's horrific.
There's dozens of massacres that
happened in the formation of Israel
because even though it was partitioned
initially by the un,
I don't know who,
who gave like this international body,
the authority to partition a country on
top of another country.
But on top of that,
um,
there was several massacres that just
continued to take more and more of the
land as I said.
And since,
and that was called the noc button.
So all these people were expelled
violently and purged From their lands.
And we visited some of these refugee
camps and the people were just like,
we literally,
our houses are like five miles away and
we're just stuck in these camps and
we've been here for 50 years.
Yeah,
it's sick.
And they have.
And they have like no water.
They just have one water tank every
month and israeli soldiers will go and
spray skunk spray,
which is like a military manufactured,
disgusting,
toxic tasting spray that sounds,
that's like tastes like sewage water.
And they'll just go target these water
tanks and then your water will be fucked
for the whole month.
There's just little things like this
just to make people's lives a living
hell.
Now.
Did you film when you were over there?
Yeah,
we have tons of.
We have tons of data.
We have what?
We have four episodes out where we,
you know,
I go to anti-refugee rallies and I'm
talking to people who are telling me
that these people are subhuman
infiltrators.
You need to be executed and rounded up
and put in chains.
It's all on film.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's really crazy and I.
You really don't understand how bad it
is and why it's so dangerous and how
really it's been the crux of so many
problems in the world,
especially in that region,
like what we've done just to create this
settler colonial state in the middle of
the middle east and expel all these
people violently and then just
unconditionally support Israel.
No matter what war crimes they commit,
no matter who they bombed,
no matter who they kill it sick and
people don't respect us for doing that
and it's super hypocritical.
When we're engaging in military
operations in the name of fucking
morality and humanitarianism.
Why do you think do openly support
Israel to where they do?
It's really weird to say like,
why do we support Saudi Arabia to Saudi
Arabia has oil.
There's some logic to connect dots.
They're really simple.
I don't believe the whole zionist lobby
controls the us.
I think that it's a partnership.
I think that the us sees a lot of
leverage having Israel there,
but I think it's becoming more unpopular
where it's almost becoming a liability
because the rest of the world is
increasingly realizing how fucked up the
situation is and trying to boycott like
the state,
you know,
and,
and the us is,
it's not going to be a popular thing.
Like even when obama was leaving office,
he did that kind of cursory like
superficial thing where they for the
first time didn't veto Israel or didn't
veto like the condemnation of israeli
settlements.
And so that was like,
we didn't not do it but we just like
didn't veto it for the first time in a
long time.
And that was a huge slap in the face to
Israel even though it was like nothing
but just as symbolic empty gesture.
But that kind of obama's like
fuck you as I was leaving,
but it really didn't do anything.
But it's just,
it shows you that there's a lot of
divisions,
I think from the inside.
And I think the government is realizing
like it might not be worth it.
Um,
if the pressure continues to,
to mountain,
I mean we need to put pressure on our
government to stop this occupation
because it's completely inhumane and
disgraceful.
So you said you have four episodes of
this that are outright four episodes and
we're putting more out.
We're putting the episode with all the
interviews with israelis next on empire
files on our,
on our show,
on youtube.
Is it just,
that's the name of the channel?
Yeah.
So empire files is the name of the
channel.
And then if you go to the empire
files.tv,
we have all of our archive on there that
you can check out.
So is this all your stuff now?
You're doing this all completely
independently?
Yup.
That's intense.
It's really intense.
Yeah.
What is it like being your own boss?
Now?
Hard because I really love smoking weed
and not procrastinating so it's really
hard to like get shit done and then I'll
be like,
oh man,
I need to put all this together.
So it's like just totally.
Me and my partner just kind of have a
deep sense of responsibility really into
somewhere like this and drop this kind
of footage.
Yes,
definitely.
And we also went to the amazon and and
saw the mess that chevron left there,
like an 18 billion gallons of oil just
festering in the amazon jungle that's
just been left real.
YeAh.
And they just lied about a bunch of pits
and never cleaned it up.
And so we went and I was like standing
in the soil pit and I was like,
what the fuck is this?
Everyone's dying of cancer.
I mean it's a whole nother level when
you're,
you know,
you're not just reacting to the news and
giving commentary.
Like we were saying before in a studio,
you're going there and it's like the
truth is in front of your face,
just the first time you've done stuff
like this.
Yeah.
So you just felt like when you were on
our t that you were kind of shackled by
being in the studio and to really get a
feel of these subjects that we're
covering.
Because I'm really emotional.
I wear my heart on my sleeve and it,
you know,
it's a detriment.
Very fiery.
Sometimes it's a detriment,
but I,
I,
you know,
I wanted to go and really be there.
I feel like I need to be connected to
the,
to the people I'm talking about and
kudos to you for doing that.
Thanks.
I'm going to wash this stuff.
I'm going to watch.
Check it out man.
I will.
And so,
empire fire arrows on youtube.
What do you have coming up?
So coming up we have um,
we're going to Venezuela.
Venezuela just fell apart,
right?
It's a dictatorship right now.
Did you hear they,
they took over the gm plant.
Well that wasn't the government actually
that came out that it was not the
government that did that,
But yet I don't know if they issued a
correction.
That was not a real story.
But yeah.
No,
it's not such a mess.
There are massive.
I mean,
can you imagine if like,
oh my god,
I don't even know,
like millions of people from both sides
are out.
Just fighting in the streets.
Like it is the craziest going there to
report subtle shot.
I know it's scary.
It's scarier.
Like 30 people have died already,
but.
oh fuck.
You know.
But I feel like we need to go and shed
some light about what the hell is going
on.
Gem fires.
Two thousand 700 employees by text
message after Venezuela plant seizure.
We all received a payment and a text
message there no longer anyone in the
country.
What does it go down?
Wow.
So they just took over the company.
They just took over the spill that.
Wait a minute.
Who's saying so what is it?
What are they saying here?
Local government is part of the south
american countries.
Ongoing economic,
political and social crisis is being
seized by the local government
illegally.
I swear to god that I saw this story
retracted,
but who knows?
Maybe this is the dr.
Com.
This is just a car site.
It's like sponsored counter reported
that thing.
It was looked like they were big.
Abandoning it for awhile though.
They've abandoned it for awhile.
Gm was going to abandon it over like.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I mean,
it's a total mess.
According to rotor routers report on
monday,
it looks like general motors is
abandoning Venezuela for awhile to
employees,
told routers that giant employee plant's
employees were all fired via text
message,
blah,
blah.
Corporate email accounts were all
deactivated over the weekend.
We received a payment in text message.
The size of the payments was not
disclosed,
were not disclosed,
but according to the union leaders,
they were too low.
Of course unions never said they paid us
perfect.
Everything's great.
We're psyched.
Yeah,
man,
it's gonna be,
it's gonna be crazy.
Bach.
So Venezuela essentially is now some
sort of a dictatorship,
right?
I don't think so.
I think that that happened.
Well,
I don't know.
Um,
Uh,
no,
not until you get there.
Well,
I've been,
I think that there's just a lot of
misinformation out there just like there
is about every country that,
you know,
rex tillerson just announced that we
want to install another regime in
Venezuela.
Chavez was a,
was a target from the us empire for a
long time.
So I just really take everything that I
read with a grain of salt,
especially in light of all the serious
stuff.
I just feel like we're in a really heavy
propaganda war.
Um,
you know,
you look back in the queue when we
actually removed hugo chavez from power
for a couple of days,
the New York times was praising it,
being a distinguished business
businessman took over,
like,
you know,
not mentioning like the us was behind
all of this.
So I just all the media talking about,
you know,
it's a dictatorship and,
and this is a pro democracy movement.
I don't doUbt that there are millions of
people who want maduro gone and they
have val absolutely valid things to say
and there's a lot of fucked up things
about the country,
mismanagement,
corruption,
et cetera.
But I'm going to go there and try to
find out what's going on.
If you want
get a chevy volt for $29,000,
the only way you do is you got to get
those vent as well and people to work
for a dollar a week.
So unless you've got a better idea,
how about you?
Fuck off.
Wait how greatest trump's economic plan,
he's like,
just give corporations giant tax breaks
and all the jobs will come back here.
You're like,
waiT.
Corporations already have giant tax
breaks and they're never going to
fucking come back here unless they can
pay people ten cents on the dollar like
they do in Bangladesh.
How is that a plan
or China?
I mean,
what were our phones?
You know,
I mean the foxconn companies don't have
nets around the,
the buildings because the job's awesome.
They have nets to keep people from
killing themselves.
That's extremely disturbing.
I mean that's the only way you get
people to make a cell phone.
This,
that cheap.
We've reviewed it like we went over the
numbers of like what a cell phone would
cost if you had it made in America and
you gave people a living wage.
It's like more than double.
Yeah.
I feel like you.
I would pay that if I knew that I waSn't
using conflict minerals,
but conflict minerals and the least of
your concern,
because this is just american labor
conflict minerals.
It's going to.
There's one company that was making an
android phone that was like karma free
phone or something like that.
Wasn'T it?
Something like along those lines,
but everyone's like,
how good.
The camera had only had like three g.
It was like a test of how much.
How much do you care?
Fuck.
three g,
five g is right around the corner.
Okay.
You got to step up your game.
Karma phone.
By the way,
judge.
You know how many emails I get from dude
saying I listen to you in the joe rogan
show and you are horribly unbecoming.
Swear too much.
You're not a lady.
You need to stop swearing.
And it makes me think what and would
what a female ever be able to win any
political office if a tape came out of
them saying,
I grabbed men by the deq.
Yeah,
that's my kind of gal.
What if.
What if I looked like trump?
Oh no,
he didn't have like all that loose skin.
But if you look like you,
but like,
yeah,
go pussy riot.
That was pussy riot.
Girls are cute,
you know,
that's why it works.
Yeah.
You know it's true.
I mean,
look,
there's a,
there's a lot of shallow thinking.
Yeah,
in,
in pretty much every part of the world.
I mean human beings are involved in this
weird sort of a race for,
for resources and for breeding rights
and for,
you know,
for social,
social position.
There's a lot of weird shit going on
with people and we're,
we're,
we're like in some weird stage of
evolution where we're,
we're close to like getting better than
we are now,
but we're not there yet.
And the trump thing is like a little
slide back.
The longing for nostalgia,
you know,
we've kind of slid back a few steps but
I always feel like my,
I mean my take on things is always that
unless there's some sort of resistance,
the real hard work doesn't get done and
I feel like this,
this situation that we're in right now,
which is really unappealing to a lot of
us is going to force people to activate
politically,
socially and gas.
And also I think
like this berkeley shit that's going on
these riots and everything is going to
force people to reexamine the way they
interact with each other.
Like this is not the functional way,
this is not a good way to interact.
And that's where I think we were talking
about like what's important about this,
um,
regressive left ideology and addressing
it and say it's important because it
fuels the right,
it fuels these alt right people to have
some sort of regressed.
Like literally what the outright to
based on the notion of.
Yeah.
I mean it really is.
Listen,
you're awesome.
I always love.
I always love having you on this time.
I was like,
I need to say more things now.
It's really depressing and clinical
prime.
Debbie martin and he didn't say shit
about sam harris,
so won't send me any horrible text.
Would you ever get together with him?
Would you ever do a podcast with him and
talk to him?
He's a very reasonable guy.
I swear to god he is.
I mean,
the thing is that is his followers are
just so crazy hidden,
sort of not like not like his man.
I mean,
wow,
I'm sure he's a nice guy,
but dance,
I think he feels like you misrepresent
what he says and then he presents it.
I say.
I mean he basically,
his whole argument was,
was tearing apart me tearing apart
official military data and statistics,
which is complete bullshit.
Anyone who believes the military and
pentagon statistics come on,
you don't think they fucking let you
think that 70,000
numbers.
Correct?
Well,
they only got a few civilians.
It was a little surgical.
I understand.
Look by a lot of my friends love sam
harris.
They love his philosophy 100 percent,
but when it comes to politics that you
know,
there's a different jive.
I think it'd be funny having two guys go
out at though.
It wouldn't be funny.
Be interesting.
It'd be.
It'd be interesting.
It'd be funny.
Interesting.
What'd you do it would you be doing
about it?
I'll think about it.
No pressure.
Pressure.
It wouldn't be fun.
It actually would be fun.
Well,
I'm glad you're back.
It was fun.
I enjoyed it.
Martin,
ladies and gentlemen,
the empire files.
Check it out on youtube.
Uh,
we'll be back tomorrow with my pal dan
dodi city.